what is up everyone tipster here but as
some of you f I'm the guy who says
cheers my dudes love you know I talk for
a moment to thank you all for joining us
for the Stevie Awards tonight live at
the Dolby Theater now before we keep
things off here I want to take a moment
to uh make a toast with me so if you got
yourself a drink go ahead and raise it
for me and at the count of
I'm going to have you all do a good
cheers my dudes for got it okay here we
go one 2 3 cheers
myud okay now with that on the way let's
go ahead and let's get this show started
take it away H3 crew love
you and Ste the now put your hands
together with your hosts of the evening
Ethan and
[Applause]
[Music]
El
[Applause]
what is up
everybody
yes it is YouTube's sexiest
night yes the streames they never
thought that we would come here and sell
out the Dolby and they're
crying we told them we'd get back at
those
that's right um everyone's
looking amazing I see everybody answered
the call formal love
that so we've got a uh action-packed fun
show for you guys so we're going to keep
it keep it clean keep it going how you
doing Ela good show up show
up look at
this I'm
shaking YouTube sexiest
night give them a twirl for for pizza's
sake you know
[Music]
up you guys are amazing all right listen
we have some special co-hosts that will
be joining us here today so with that
being said can uh the hosts please join
us on stage that's right we have Jeff
Whit tana and Logan
Paul that's
[Applause]
right
wow wow wow wow go you guys sit here
hello
family
[Music]
Jeff yes we have everybody's favorite
it's practically Tradition at this point
but I'm ruining my career tonight that's
right they love you so beyond cancell
tonight so am I I don't want to do let's
go you can bail he's scar out of me
I want to go back to Crime so the the
biggest surprise of the night is that
Logan Paul is actually joining us
here you know we it's great to be here
guys thanks I'm going to kill myself in
front of all of you wait who who sorry
can I not say that at you can but come
on it's a tree I can say that all right
you're going to kill yourself if I can
say that anywhere I can say you should
not say that next Logan hey guys let's
not make any suicide jokes today okay oh
be please I forgot about the
forest he's sensitive I'm definitely
getting kicked off impulsive after this
yeah Mike was supposed to be here by the
way but I think Logan pulled the plug on
that and who would have thought that I
showed up and Mike would have bailed
girl I knew you would show up you always
come through for me I'll show up for you
H3 always so um thank you guys everyone
you look
stunning up next we have the hardest
working crew in the
game you know them you love them they
bring it
all they're the whole Triple Threat
bring out the H3 crew guys come on out
here
yeah a Lena Love Olivia
Sam we're missing some oh no we're
not Dan and K
and young Zachariah where's
Zachariah where is
Zach I know he's somewhere else but
there he is get come on Zach show your
face
hey they are the best in the
game so let's take a look here so we
have a huge huge night with amazing
categories you guys this really is
YouTube's sexiest night I mean let's
take a look at this you know who did you
have to sacrifice to sell out the Dolby
Theater a lot basically the Oscar and
the Grammys are held here I know that I
know and like here we are as we said as
we the streams would they would not
sell out a one row like it is just
abysmal the show that they put on it's
frankly embarrassing shame on them you
know I figured I'd be your hosting a
show where they host the Oscars but I
never thought I'd be here with you Ethan
yeah yeah you know when we when we first
met you had me on the show when I had my
brain all smashed in and I was on a
bunch of
drugs and now we're best friends you
know you're a good man je really we've
come a long way I TR I trust you man I
can always depend on you and you too
Tana he just looked at me and he goes
this is awesome and in my head I was
like you're nothing like
Logan Logan would never say this is
awesome he just did I just did Logan how
you feeling oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I am
sitting in the same spot Chris Rock got
slapped at uh we're not supposed to say
that no and if and if you were your
brother I'd be getting slapped in the
spot us they told us no sorry kidding
hopefully you got the button D that was
the one rule you told me we talk about
the one thing they said don't we can not
talk about the Will Smith situation was
the one rule you gave me but you didn't
tell me anything else Jeff you hit me
last night okay that was consensual
so uh let's see here anyway thank you
we've got wow so many categories so it's
been such a big year you know uh so much
to cover so I think we should just jump
into it you know let's just get right
into it let's get right in with our
first category which is going to be
worst National
discourse all right and that is
presented by our very own Cameron
Grant I'm out
cam hello
everybody how you
doing sweet I prepared a few words uh in
between panic attacks tonight so take a
anx
what good evening to my brothers sisters
and non-binary siblings in the audience
tonight yes what an honor and a
privilege it is to present tonight's
first award of the
2023 steamy
Awards as the stupidest crew member I
jumped at the opportunity to introduce
the nominees for worst National brain
rot
discourse uh I'd like to start this
video by quoting those Immortal words
from the everyone's favorite dumbass
idiot loser DJ killer keemstar
love you roll it worst National brain
rot discourse Taylor Swift starts dating
Travis Kelsey did you really hey man I
don't did you really have your phone
number ready on a friendship bracelet to
give to T I said what I said and I meant
what I said when I said sh sh you know
what it is what it is I'm not the
internet's going to break the rumors
apparently are true Taylor Swift is
friends with Travis Kelce I think the
Secret's out who's she here to see I
think we can uh play matchmaker and put
the rumors to rest I think they are
officially a couple
in Selena Gomez vers Haley Bieber Haley
and Justin have remained silent
meanwhile Selena is now coming out to
say a few words to her supporters please
please be kinder and consider others
mental health my heart has been heavy
and I only want good for everyone I
don't think that this is about Haley
Bieber and Selena Gomez this is not
about hitting between two women and
division between two women it's about
vile disgusing hatred that can come from
completely made up and twisted and
perpetuated narratives what happened to
the missing Titanic submarine a
submersible vessel has gone missing in
the Atlantic ocean I couldn't help
noticing how many pieces of this sub
seemed improvised we run the whole thing
with this game
control come on at some point safety
just is pure waste we have new
developments of the Titan sub merciful
all five people on board were killed
freaks mad at Chris from Mr Beast
Southern gun and truck loving dude yet
beginning in March 2022 Chris began to
display increasingly feminine TR traits
with this same kind of look showing up
in his Mr Beast appearances others even
made the claim that KL had turned him
gay grandmother together social media
it's never too late to start being
yourself the only clean solution might
be for Chris to resign himself and even
then rumors and bad press will be
unavoidable yeah this is getting absurd
Chris isn't my nightmare he's my effing
friend and things are fine all this
transphobia is starting to piss me off
Starfield pronoun outr
age pronouns gender ambiguity
current Day California so you can
current dayers no no no current
day into everything every single sry
thing very
good all right what what a I mean that's
a that's a stiff category some
enlightening stuff on there could go
either way man I could go any way there
all right and the winner for worst
National brain rot discourse
is freaks mad at Mr
[Applause]
beast wow congratulations to the freaks
you're this year's winner I'm going to
read off the the percentage here I'm not
kid I was thinking about my nail color
like I fully disassociated are you yeah
what color should I get pink or blue
nails
next okay perfect Mr Beast is not here
to accept the award what Mr Beast is not
here to accept the W Mr Beast is not
here to accept the W though it's not for
him it's for the freaks he can last so
it's like the streamy I just accept it
on his behalf you wanted you could take
it for him I mean Logan Paul you're
friends with with uh Jimmy I yeah he
planted a million trees and I fake
married Jake Paul and I somehow won the
award so yeah whatever he's a demon
anyway we send his award down to hell
for it plant a be fans here so
I'll leave it with you Logan I think
that has his best shot to get plant a
tree well here we go let's see
freaks mad at Mr Beast 30% Taylor Swift
Travis Kelce 20% Starfield pronouns 18%
I love that guy man I I really wanted it
to be him but you know Titan submarine
was 15% that was a strong Contender
Selena versus Haley nobody cares about
him
15.3% this the very last what do you
guys think are these surprising
results whoa all right well we love
Chris and
uh we love him her oh my God we love her
oh we love her damn it good job Ally jut
let's restart it let's restart the whole
show said Ally I'm so sorry you know I
try my best I really
do I I did want to give a shout out to
all the
gays or
however Sunny says it all right thank
you very good well um up next we've got
a
really really prolific category I think
this huge Contender biggest cringe
moment o this is big this is being
presented by our very own ab and
Lena
Lena and it's not the plug baby my boy
AB Lena and there's no Adam
[Music]
Insight hi guys uh we didn't really
prepare a speech um but Lena looks great
well thank
you all have sex have sex okay I'm
waiting I'd watch the tape 10 times more
than Lena the plug hell yeah
um my mom is here somewhere but I can't
find her mom where you at oh hi Mom oh
there she is we're good friends me and
your mom we talk we talked a bit when
you were I pulled her aside we had a lot
of good deep personal conversations
thank you do you want to say
anything no are you single mom or are
you seeing
anyone are you single no I'm I'm married
yeah just okay anyway the
nominees
I'm single and
desperate there it is we got to auction
you off man biggest
cringe dream puts the mask back on dream
has officially reded his favorite mask
after removing it in a face reveal last
year in a moment the entire internet
seemed to have an unhealthy obsession
with ever since you took this stupid
mask off You' fallen off you're
irrelevant
excuse does the worm during debate
people would rather watch me full screen
C do the worm and watch your
then watch your Prime content for a week
do a week of no reaction content and see
how many views you get oh he's
crying in the
corner oh okay sure I mean that's
content man it's it's original content
at least like it yes do that bro like
FaZe Rain attacks Grace f done the grace
recently joining fa Clan and saying that
she and the organization quote will be
working together to create lasting
change for female gamers in the industry
but upon joining the group Bly found
herself in the middle of this massive
Feud with B rain if you not hit a trick
shot but you don't even know what the
that is you're excruciatingly mid who I
would never let touch me on my drunk I
know you as the person who almost overd
dosed on a live stream I know that
you're better now I'm really proud of
you for that but don't come after me for
not knowing what a trick shot is man how
dare you bring up the worst time of my
life I'm hurt
how dare you see I can play that
game all day I'm an actor too
Logan Paul threatens coffee Zilla with a
lawsuit is he is a lopsided journalist
agenda more like an internet criminal
oops the defamation that is Happ this is
wrong this is wrong we're going to
handle this ourselves while we continue
to build crypto zoo and I'll see you in
court C Zill is not a criminal oh that's
a relief I thought logo was going to
hire me boogie
2988 job interview tell me a little bit
about your background yeah I completely
and utterly lost my mind I am disabled
uh recognized by the state of Arkansas
but also the United States government uh
I I am morbidly obese I have no
references no work history and no
education when you Google my name you
might see rumors that I beat my ex-wife
and I I'm also a pedophile uh but that
could be an issue Fus terrorizes Japan
I'm going to travel across Japan for
free people pay when they go out of the
bus so hopefully he doesn't ask me to
pay I couldn't believe it he locked me
in the bus and drove me to the police
station he was just waiting to catch me
so the only thing I could do is to
pretend that I'm
sick this is a
wow good
now okay by the way and the winner
is xqc does the work wow what an honor
congratulations
xqc there there was some really good
entries man I mean you want to read them
off how they how they broke out there
Ela yes so xqc won with 36%
and then Boogie job interview
27% okay my personal Favorite Dream puts
the mask back on
18% fidus terrorizes Japan
6% well 6.7 actually cuz Logan threatens
cazila
6.2% oh what about Logan Mike is not
here and he not able to do a little
stronger three of the five people in
that category tried to me and I
think really
I think it could be a fun game trying to
figure out who yeah that is so let's see
hold on that is a so Boogie is the first
one
Boogie honestly no he's sa let's see and
last one was FaZe Rain vers Grace with
four so three of these guys tried to
you did dream try to you I
know you guys always talk I thought it
was a fun bit like for the viewers at
home like to guess who you know do you
want me to guess you're not the view at
home babe you're in a suit on the stage
all right so I think yeah really Logan
you tried to get it that no it was a fun
game it was a fun game for the viewers
okay okay I'm retired there's a
lot of people like I'm a reformed
keep that in mind okay okay Logan you're
up for an award congratulations how are
you feeling dude I'm feeling pumped
thank you I feel that 6.2 could have
done a little more okay 6.2 that's it
yeah it's for scamming people the crypto
by the way it wasn't that bad 6.9 would
have been perfect 6 not
69 tag yourself who want a
[Applause]
shirt we spent like $2,000 on this the
craziest shirt cannon we could
buy let's see here if I shoot someone in
the front row you will die so
I'm not going to do that so let's take a
look here last lawsuit of the Year
baby
[Applause]
don't get in a fist fight it'll look
just like tanacon like let's keep it
let's keep it right you know no one can
die here we've got a whole bunch of
these by the way I can't have two live
events that people almost die at so did
you say it's a tampon a used tampon huh
did you say I shot a used tampon tanacon
the festival she threw where all the
people di events that at kidding no one
died at tanacon kidding thank you guys
thank you have a good night
thank you want to shoot something you
want to shoot one of these off no come
on take a shot bro all
right we we've got a whole stack yeah
yeah yeah they saying do
it yeah oh you shocked me bro an
electric so you want to
just click that down yeah then it's
going to fill up real
nice okay now just go for it
[Applause]
[Music]
bro whoa y God that's
legit they made it all the way up to the
balcony row yo you know what they call
this thing the bleacher Reacher they
weren't kidding around man that's
awesome yeah
good
shot there it
is um tonight is not just to honor the
uh the greats of creators of our
community it's also to
honor the musical Talent uh one of our
big categories is best influencer song
and throughout the evening we are going
to have each one of those songs
performed live for
you yes live
music and so with that being
said young Zachariah
here we'll be playing for you guys our
first musical act
[Applause]
rectangular
woo hi3 fam it's Sean Stevens here I'm
sorry I couldn't make the live show but
we are traveling
12,352 km to go climb Mount kilamanjaro
you're the only people that we are
telling uh because you are our favorite
we love you so much and I'm sorry I
couldn't make it because we really
wanted to be with you but we're going to
have fun and we are going to promote our
next major release Circle can't wait
sorry I missed you guys love you all
[Applause]
[Music]
bye I
amang I feel my bones I am
rectangular feel no I am
rectangular and you are a circle am
rectangular
no hold I am
rectang and you are a ccle I am
[Music]
rectangular a lost so I am
rectangular the
world I
[Music]
amang try
toou
[Music]
the I feel it in
myones you
[Music]
are I'm
lost
hold hold
down W
[Music]
up
don't how I find you how I
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
wow Zach I think you got to smash the
guitar after that wow you're going to
have to set that thing on fire bro you
got to retire that guitar after that
performance go flashing
yeah you're good you're he can't hear me
that was amazing
bro you guys know about rectangular I
mean it's a Smash Hit of the Year you
guys read that one no if I was Tak I'd
him T just ask me mer tits she
wants what T just asked me if she should
show him her tits you want to show your
tits well no Jeff suggested that but
he's my keeper so can Jeff's a cuck Jeff
wants to see me show can she show her
tits Dan can you show your tits on the
show uh I don't yeah I'm pretty sure not
pretty sure not she's just she really
liked his performance dude absolutely
that's usually how it goes um yeah he's
he's the rectangular guy I mean he's
really a sensation he's he's a square I
guess which is a type of rectangle yeah
it's the best type of rectangle thanks
bro I back you up on that LP boy Logan
Paul my boy
you're a cellout baby I love Paul you're
killing it wrestling by the way killing
it you're awesome bro
cellout you're just jealous bro you
remember when you tasered that dead rat
that was sick that was sick I was so
sick remember that it was like a week
after the forest the suicide forest yeah
you like went to the you went to the
forest and then you found the body and
all that and then you went home and
tasered a dead rats hey wait wait we
weren't making any suicide jokes earlier
remember what we're not going to talk
about suicide should I kill myself is
this the height of my career and I
should kill myself absolutely is that
what you're asking I would prefer not
but that is up to you give me a forest
and a Pikachu hat babe oh the Pikachu
hat be
fire that Mouse did not commit suicide
but there's no Forest so we're or was it
not Pikachu what was
it look it's been long enough I think we
can finally admit Logan also killed that
guy right I was that guy okay statue
limitations is up who cares he's not
what what are they going to do extra
items
Japan oh you killed someone whatever
they don't even have jails over there
yeah I'm just going to avoid that part
of the world for right now we're good if
Logan asked you to bend over right now
you'd do it I know it the I'm not M
wrong guy up next my
friends this has been a feud that's been
happening uh for the better part of a
decade t
there's a man named idubz on the
internet that you've had quite a quite a
journey with frankly that's my best
friend we just went shopping together
yesterday well there has been an
interesting Arc hasn't there where he
issued a pretty sincere apology and and
you accepted it right I of course I
accepted it yeah I was going to tell you
what we went shopping for but that would
be something you shouldn't say on live
bad joke sorry go ahead what was it it's
like the hats you know kidding
you want to tell her to stop knock it
off straight out will you will you keep
your friend in order please Jee all
right let's probably going to have to
cut her mic soon keep giving her Tequila
No it's been a really really long time
and I think the growth of two people who
have been very hectic and horrible
online you hated me for a long time for
how I acted online I didn't hate you but
you I love you now you you really are
ter I think certain things like that
bring a lot of grow Logan Paul I ha I
love but I but you know I'm in my I'm in
my civil happy era and I love to see
growth it makes really proud so would it
be okay uh my friend Ian also known as
ubbs is here would it be okay if he made
an apology to you
now would that be okay only if you're
okay with it I don't want to make you
uncomfortable I mean it is up to you if
you told 2017 me this was happening she
would have stopped taking drugs so
that's
sick so yes no this could have prevented
an overdose honestly four years ago yeah
we did plan this ahead of time so you
guys yeah you're just doing shtick you
keep Naran on on lock at the H3 offices
yeah I didn't spring this on you okay
yeah with that being said well let's
just Ian come come come show yourself
out here besie get out here
bud
besti welcome to the stage my friend I'm
going to ship myself I'm going to
myself I hope the top row is well aware
to watch me myself have you guys
seen each other since the uh faded the
word for a moment backstage yeah oh like
just but like today so today's the first
time you guys have seen each other
that's my girly over there hi girly
PP well this is your chance you and I
know you you have a lot of making up to
do and we all support
you yeah so
uh
man this is did so much harder than
boxing jeez okay uh Tana at the
beginning of the show you said something
about killing yourself I think that was
pretty
extreme uh hold off on that what is he
say let's hold off on that I wonder if
need and I I think this isn't the end of
you saying extreme things I think you're
prone to saying very bizarre you're
the top of my Suicide not
baby you're right there dear ubbs I'm
hanging now sorry we're
live because of that I have designed a
cancellation gift basket thank you just
for you it explodes in my face this is
my death you all watch
[Music]
it uh it looks like it packs a punch
what's that I said it looks like it
packs a punch I think you really helped
me
grow cool you helped me grow a lot as a
person sorry it's kind of hard to here I
wish we had all good go ahead uh so yeah
love you Logan it's a it's not a
traditional gift basket so it needs a
little bit of explanation the items
inside of it so I've prepared a video
for you all to see and uh T like here is
your 500,000 subscribers you
[Music]
lost is that right Jeff has open you've
been counting Jeff has open it Jeff has
open it I'm just I'm not touching this
from this Nut
Job okay I'm just a girl I'm just a
girl I'm not opening this sh all
right so let's go ahead and roll Ian a
video wait since it's a boxing glove can
she nail you one time like oh oh
do it do it hit him hard what's the
Worst That Could Happen she's a woman
2017 me would have came for that but
like we're we're okay now I don't want
to hit you one time come on I have
better people to hit you can hit him do
you care about me those are 10 o gloves
by the way those those are serious what
those are 10 o gloves so those really
hurt you don't know what that means oh
they're small you sound like my ex and
now I'm is this on the table T maybe
going for a shot
don't puss out bro do it what's she G to
do she not going to do anything Dr Mike
didn't
do a beast warning my sense of humor may
hurt your feelings he should have
changed out feelings with income D did
you bring a prop with you okay you're
spoiling some of the jokes all right let
me let's play the video so that's not so
that whole thing isn't ruined no go
ahead with is it the one I think it is
do we get a sensor at
[Music]
least hello if you're watching this
video chances are you have been given a
gift basket you have likely been given
this because you have been identified by
a friend or family member as having very
high
lurb lurb is the likelihood of engaging
in Risky Behavior many people struggle
with lurb every day I struggle with lurb
every day and here are some of my
patients who struggle with lurs every
day in your basket you will find two
strange cartoon DVDs if you called your
wife a on live stream you are
going to want to pop in the DVD player
Death Note this will get you through a
48h hour cancellation now on the other
end of the spectrum's say you say
something a bit more unforgivable uh
you're going to want to batten down the
hatches with this this fuzzy little guy
his name is Monkey D Luffy you might not
know who he is now but he's going to be
your best friend for the next 6 Seven 8
months next up we have uh just a lot of
merch that says sarcastic things like
warning my sense of humor may hurt
feelings now this is included in the
basket just so that people around you
kind of get the idea that you're just a
little bit up in the head up next
we have this little button now other
content creators may spend upwards of
$20,000 on a button that will cut a live
stream feed uh this costs a fraction of
that so let's say you're going on a
tangent and you're like it you know
what I'll just say it I think that we
should arm the
teachers in Minecraft and you know what
I think we
should arm the students too and I think
we should send the students overseas and
they should be doing The Killing For
Us in Minecraft the button can also work
if you do or say something that's just a
little embarrassing hey welcome everyone
I'm will we hitting the I'm wi hitting
the
everyone in Minecraft dab dab I'm
dabbing on my haters I'm dabbing in
Minecraft the next item we have is
called could be worse it's a children's
book it basically shows you that you
could be carried away by a giant Falcon
to be ripped apart in the mountains of
Tibet but some people are just mad at
you on Twitter last item in the
cancellation
basket are these these these are great
because obviously if you've been
cancelled you have a lot of pent up rage
you you need to let that rage out and uh
it's also great because if you've been
cancelled you're probably pretty bad
with your words so maybe it's time to
give your fist a chance to do the
talking thank you for watching this
presentation I hope that this
cancellation basket is able to help you
cope with your current or future
cancellations goodbye
goodbye
uh-oh she's coming to give a punch look
right into this camera with me uhoh save
forgiveness that was good that was good
you had me sweating though for a
minute what if she did what if she
actually said
it that would have been so unexpected
and crazy kidding kidding what else can
you do imagine being me what else are
you going to do I have a question who do
you think has higher l lurb uh what else
are you gonna you definitely
have higher lurb you think I have higher
lurb than T what who's got higher lurb
higher what yeah that
was okay well at least you're just a
girl I'm just a
girl you know um I'm really inspired by
the apology you make and just how much
you've grown as a person you know it's
it's inspiring me to make my own apology
uh Logan Paul I'd like to say some words
to you if you don't
mind
no I'm serious well I've been thinking
listen um God we've been through so much
since the first time I saw you at Na's
house by the red Mustang you guys
mentioned that story but it wasn't cool
for me to make fun of your color
blindness that's a disability man he
just up and I I really uh I'm
going to go ahead and just cut you off
right there bro there's no need to
apologize okay you've done nothing wrong
fact I'm sorry okay I have overreacted
and overstepped and I need to just go
ahead and apologize I love you bro I've
been a fan of your podcast for years
really oh my God yes in fact your
podcast is way better than mine so I
have been grinding and emul I can't
believe you said that like Ethan thank
you man oh I love your hair thank you I
know yeah I love the hair line I'm
jealous of it thank you bro Logan that's
so nice of you to say wow so humble give
it up for Ethan guys woo all right I
love Logan Paul he's he's actually a
really cool dude what's not to love
about me I'm awesome thank you bro love
that it's inspiring moment we're we're
really all growing and learning so much
he said our podcast is better than his I
mean that's a really a bull Brave thing
to say on camera just speaking the truth
bro facts wow thank you bro it's a night
of
forgiveness what do you isn't there a
Jewish holiday about forgiveness what is
it called oh um yum K is this is Yum Kor
are we koring it up I don't know happy
kapor
brother thanks
Ian yeah I could hear about 10% of what
you guys are saying yeah we yeah you
kind of just got a prend well just trust
that 100% of it is awesome okay just
pretend basically that but thank but
thank you you can leave the stage now
all test test thank
you Want
Me Oh wait we're doing an award together
oh I'm sorry you can stay actually no
you want me to leave absolutely not
actually we're doing this one uh
together you have an envelope what's
that we're doing this one
together I we I have one too oh okay
cool should we pull it at the same you
pull yours okay yeah guys wait do we
even hold on hold on hold on guys roll
the video
worst
apology Logan Paul coffeezilla I watched
a three-part series called investigating
Logan Paul's biggest scam and like many
on this platform you have successfully
used my name for views and money your
addiction to clicks has clouded your
judgment so in this video today I'm
going to be defending myself with facts
something that you have gotten in the
habit of twisting as you continue to
morph from an investigator to a gossip
Channel I'll see you in court Coffee
Zill is not I called him I apologize
thank you coffeezilla Ashton Kutcher and
me
lunis he received the maximum sentencing
of 30 Years to Life on Thursday over two
rape conviction and sometime after that
news broke we later learned that both
Ashton and mil are among dozens of
people who wrote to the judge in support
of him before his sentencing we are
aware of the pain that has been caused
by the character letters that we wrote
on behalf of Danny
Master we support victims Sniper Wolf
sniper wolf shot back in a handful of
posts on her Instagram story saying his
claims are defamation and she doesn't
know how to do and adding he literally
posted his address on Google and said I
threatened him and dox him and adding
this creep has been harassing me for
months then plays victim saying I
threatened him when I just wanted to
talk to him I have no ill intentions
this guy's entire channel is just me me
me every single video for the past few
months has been about me this dude is
just like lowkey harassing me like
should I get a restraining order let me
start by saying I'm sorry for my recent
actions it is inexcusable I'm sorry to
Jack film YouTube the entire Creator
community and my incredible fans for not
being a better example for appropriate
conflict
resolution
Ballinger how can she not
[Music]
win made a
mistake
doesn't
wow who better to present this together
than the guys who have the most
apologies honestly I'm learning if I had
a good editor for my apology to him I
probably would have made it
further what she say what' she say
you're doing pretty good she's hammered
I'm sure it was good awesome that was
awesome all right let's go together
we'll do like a cute thing where we do
on three and all that I mean don't you
have to do oh we it's the same thing
really I think so best apology all right
oh no this is a Dan what's happening
wait hold on why'd you give us the thing
to read jum the gun
buddy so I'm not on this the next
category is best apology which is what
you're presenting Ethan you can go ahead
and go ahead we love you okay the worst
apology goes
to of you Colleen
Binger I mean this is really Colleen's
here and congratulations to her really
um well do she uh she swept the category
getting
86.9%
wow you can read them all you want to
read next time I have to apologize to
you I'm getting a
harp I'm going to be like this I'm sorry
Ian please don't make another content
cop here's my harp uh number two Ashton
MAA 8
8.2% Sniper Wolf second place got 8.2
dude she killing Colleen this is your
year girl
that's nuts uh Sniper Wolf at 2.5 and
Logan Paul at two
Logan yes you know that wasn't that bad
what Logan did what he did you know um
that's me being a scamming part yeah you
know what's funny about that video the
apology one he showed me and Mike at his
house or Logan showed uh me and Mike at
his house and I was like hell yeah bro
post that that's going to
Crush yeah and yeah we were
wrong you previewed the coffeezilla and
you hyped him up yeah I was like fire
dog y That's So Sick that I'm be
straight up that's one of the
weirdest dumbest AP like he's like I'm
going to sue your ass my
apology could have been a little
better I still strongly believe in
crypto Zoo what's that Logan yeah my
apology could have been better but I
still strongly believe in crypto zo yeah
yeah no it's it's just still a really
good investment I'm sure too it was a
good app good app solid investment
thanks bro um I'll I'll in I'll buy some
later today for sure I'd appreciate that
a lot but like but like the turnaround
of being like I'm suing you you scumbag
too sorry bro and thank you by the way
for just a little playful banter between
so special yeah that part was whack he
should have just called out coffeezilla
to a boxing
match right like real smoke
I can go back to my seat now yeah you
can leave the stage now for real thank
you Ian thank you so
much we love
you what I beautiful Mo his mullet is
like out of control this is all over the
place you're really working on that an
authentic mullet you know like really
old school mullet he's just it's all
greasy and crazy
hold on he he just asked me he goes wait
should I not say anything about crypto
zo like he's I mean the lawsuit is still
going down well I mean whatever your
lawyer said yeah probably not you know
technically because you do still owe
like I don't know like $2 million of
restitution we don't really know we
don't that's like jump change that's
what he said he's like I'm going to give
like $2 million and he he hasn't done it
yet you haven't done it yet he didn't do
anything wrong I'm working on it though
okay just it's don't take time but trust
me results are coming take time drink
Prime stay hydrated feeling fine by the
way
Crush um I want to give a side note this
stage is so epic and you know who did
it Sam built this whole stage
Sam right there is that
crazy no for Sam Sam has been going nuts
man this whole time
really amazing work
soon thank
you I feel like she ODS her shoulder was
falling apart her finger cut off thank
you so much yeah she
cut how's your finger she cut a tip off
just the
tip you're okay oh Logan just T
Mayo for Sam you're off the
show all right so this is actually my
category uh uh this is something that I
know a little bit about uh did worst
apology but this one is actually best
apology so a coveted category we have a
video never once had one well let's see
the
nominees hello my name is Dr Kirk Honda
from the psychology and Seattle YouTube
channel and I feel extremely honored to
be here at the steamies to present the
category of best apology and the
nominees Are drum
roll best
apology Ethan
Klein hello everybody I wanted to come
here and
discuss uh the situation with CD
Cinderella someone who I actually really
want to support may have felt uh worse
on an already difficult situation
because of my careless and uh very very
inappropriate and gross and stupid
Behavior right and you know it's not the
first time I've done it this was weird
like I don't know
why like obviously there's something off
about me
right cuz I always find myself in these
situations where I am doing and saying
impulsive things that uh I regret right
I got to give him an A+ right in terms
of a public apology this is A+
well let's see uh let's see who
won all right open the category here and
oh my God you
guys with 93% where' the other seven go
there's only one choice I trust those
numbers Ethan Klein you guys oh my
God oh my God this is such a surprise
I'm just so honored it was a really good
apology
thank you thank you oh my
god wow this is so
meaningful uh I do I I I just really you
know I'm just so touched there's
feedback is that are you guys trying to
tell me to to wrap it
up oh you know yeah is that is that yeah
that don't sound good is my body
vibrating is your vibrator on or what's
going
on
any anyway guys uh oh now my mic doesn't
work you can use
mine we love it folks don't we anyway
thank you guys so meaningful so
unexpected so special actually we had
rtings the most written in were ubbs oh
come on his was are better than mine I
mean no no no
offense A+ come on Colleen what the
who wrote that who wrote
that and quote anyone
else all right listen
wow you are good at
apologizing thank you so much I take a
page out of your book if I need to again
well he made so many people apologize
you should be good at it you know you
ruin so many
lives well who's yeah they had it coming
though probably I think you're good at
everything Ethan thanks I know I love
you you you're the man Logan yeah
you're so cool I I had you wrong all
years Jeff I love you bro I love you bro
I get lost in your eye all day I'm going
to throw
up there's a bucket behind you they were
expecting
that thanks bro yeah so um anyway you're
staying with us since you're in town
you're going to finish cleaning the
house tomorrow right just take care of
the toilet halfway done dude thanks BR
he going happen he's he's so helpful I
know that makes your dick
hard oh yeah nothing makes my dick hard
like Logan Paul cleaning my toil nothing
gets his dick hard he heard it you guys
heard it I got a hard dick except
me not right now for
the all right so ridiculous you
have to recous ridiculous
so um you got to love every moment up
next this is someone I haven't met but
I'm very excited to you guys might
recall a special video on YouTube it got
tens of millions of views a little video
of a nice sweet guy naring his
[Music]
butthole coolest Kev where are
you bring that tight little caress
butthole out here
so nice to meet
you nice to meet you
man I want to sh and P go ahead go ahead
yeah I want to sh and piss at the same
time cuz I'm so nervous that like
there's so many people here I'm freaking
out I'm like sweating my pits are wet
right now well you've shown your
butthole to like I don't think I'm going
to do that like here I feel like that's
inappro you want to do that I think I'm
I think not today guys it's hairy right
now so you know do you regret that video
or are you happy with it what what what
was the deal with that video I'm pretty
happy with it cuz I got a lot of
attention for it so you know I'm like
the biggest attention horse so I love
that people like watch me n my ass even
though I did get some haters from it but
who cares does it surprise you that it's
not it's not age restricted right no it
is yeah but like somehow like miners
found it they found you yeah and they're
like watching it but it's not in like an
arousing way so it's fine well speak for
yourself it's not I'm never here to
sexually gratify ever like ever I was I
was sure it was a fetish thing but you
deny that you did say that and I like
saw clips of you saying that and I like
lowkey was like upset about it really
you heard my feelings yeah but you can
understand I'm sorry should I do one of
my iconic apologies
yeah bro I am so so so sorry that you
spreading your cheeks wide open
and naring the hair out of your
yeah who and you get me here now well
actually since you're a pro at naring we
have um a special segment planned here
obviously we can't show butthole but we
can show belly hole Yeah you could like
we could cosplay as like like make your
belly button cosplay as like an
will will you show me how to n
absolutely yeah okay let's do
it suspicious looking N Bottle just
sitting right here is there a cam we
need a closeup for this one guys cuz
yeah oh we're doing it here yeah we're
doing it right okay can I put like a
paper towel
[Music]
oh can I like wash my hands after
or
tighter
tighter you all right we're ready for
you buddy oh okay so step one obviously
is to put the nare cream in your hand
but I don't want to like dry my hands or
like you know them up so here we go
let's put a let's put a lot for the for
the cameras did you use a lot in the in
the anus I was surprised that you didn't
have a lot of hair in your butle to
begin with no I was super hairy oh maybe
you're like Chewbacca level but I I mean
I'm Asian so you know my turds hang on
like it's a jungle gym
go ahead go
ahead so step two what is in your belly
button
bro did you hide that no and you can see
the rest on uncensored you guys having a
hairy belly button for some
reason I always have lint there just
always do you want this oh
sure all right so $9.99 a month you can
see the rest on Tana so step two is to
rub it all over the desired area that's
like super hairy and Ethan is obviously
super hairy so let's just cream pie holy
do you you don't cream pie thanks
bro I got on my finger wait do you
usually use that much uh no I just
thought it would be more uh
cinematic well the the goal is to you
know get the hair out of there yeah so
is that it do we need to so we leave
that there for like 3 to 5 minutes you
can't tell me this isn't but you should
set a timer cuz if it goes five past 5
minutes you will burn oh my God yeah I
burned my like micro the other day so
your micro penis you have a micro for
real it's not an actual micro penis but
like people called it a micro so I was
like I'm going to just take back the
word why do okay you're re you're
reclaiming it yeah it's like when people
use other words that I'm not going to
say and they take it back and you
know right right right you know I mean
listen us guys little penis solidarity
Brothers I mean that that it's we need
we need to be there yeah you're like the
MLK of tiny penises
man how big's your
dick let's focus on my belly button here
wait can we set a timer or not do I need
to rub it in no no you don't rub it in
oh you just oh my God
that's yeah
well what about
inside um inside of what the belly
button the belly button I mean if you
want like a super smooth hole you should
finger your hole with the cream well
we're here for smooth holes my friend
that's the whole
point all right I got this all over
me okay so has it been 3 to four minutes
what what we'll do while it's set why
don't you go ahead and present the next
award for unh hinged Creator let me just
wipe the nare on my fingers go ahead and
roll the video it's all on my hands so
I'm just going to hopefully I don't burn
I sizz I'm so aroused to present to
you
infra I just want you to know the cops
have been called they are on their way
it's bread
buddy D you fooled huh Breen Bren Bren
yeah uh remember dolphin 955 huh
I had you
fooled
two you what's up I I don't it's good
stuff I I don't drink it's made for
fitches but humans can drink it too
[Laughter]
huh lis
[Music]
saunderson
fish gar hey guys I'm in the Florida
Everglades and I'm using my feet to
attract this swamp puppy Mr Crocodile is
coming in hot I think he's about to yink
me it's not easy looking for a 20ft
burmes python especially when you don't
stage your videos that juicy cotton
mouth you got to watch your step out
here
yoink I'm in the Florida Everglades and
this swamp puppy sure isn't happy with
me and look what I just stumbled across
this is one of the biggest swamp puppies
I've ever seen and he sure is
intimidating look at that big head but
this crocodile is way bigger I'm inches
away from this huge 12T American
crocodile check him out Dr Kenny
Smiles oh my gosh your teeth actually
match your jacket go and put those
babies
in yeah you're going to get for
the first time for sure those are right
out of a Halloween catalog
mhm no pain to rain chiropractor
massive scoliosis that's been cooking up
for lots and lots of
years
good oh yeah good movement there huh
yeah all right Mr rain relax that head
for me oh there it
is you got charged up
[Music]
now wow
wow all healing takes time that this is
an Amazon Prime right big Nick yoga
literally means yoke and you're yoking
with these demonic Hindu deities come
out right now the name of come out right
now in the name of Jesus feminism is a
demonic movement created by Satan I just
don't like feminism it's cringe the
coolest
C body cream hair remover for reference
this is how hairy my butt is right
now this is how my butt looks post
shower post rents and post hair removal
cre oh my God thank you guys so much for
watching
wow and the winner for most unhinged
Creator goes
to if it's not me I'm buying a gun and
I'm shooting myself in the head with it
I'm just kidding I'm do that sorry this
is
not oh my God it's me yeah I can't
believe I won thanks so much for voting
for me Kev look
oh cool is
Kev congratulations man thank you so
much congratulations congratulations bro
your ass we should probably move on with
this would been way over 5 minutes yeah
you should uh you should this is not my
most flattering moment either oh yeah
maybe you should remove should we REM
way way Kevin this stinks bro yeah
I mean I got some my hand smells like
burnt hair and now on the award too wait
hold on if smell
that it's crazy right should I help you
take it off or are you come here yeah
will you yeah it's crazy
bad and like the but my belly button
already smells bad enough oh yeah it's
burning um
big reveal you guys three two
one oh my
God oh my
God that's crazy that
should there's no way that's safe for
human
skin it should be used for
like show show the towel yes there it is
guys
proof we're going to need some how about
I use it I use a shirt and then shoot it
into the
audience no I'm not going to do that use
his
pants I can't I can't really actually do
that can
I that's
wild you guys want my Nar belly button
[Applause]
here okay don't clone me though ra oh my
God hair where's the camera I guess you
do give Chewbacca look at this bro
what did you do to me look at this
oh my God what the that's a lot of
hair dude you put too much on me
bro sorry I wanted to I got excit need
to wash it um I would suest is falling
off do we need soap I suggest washing
some of it off with water and soap oh my
God what thank you bro not too hard bro
my SK my skin is peeling off doesn't
bother me at all look at this you like
that get in there get in there baby now
lick it and you can see the rest on Tana
uncensored for only 9.99 a month enough
enough bu belly buttons on your only
fans honestly yeah okay didn't clear
that you and hila have a baby to pay for
what else can I do am I really shooting
this oh my God this look at
me it works hold on bring the camera
back I mean this this is really this is
unbelievable this is dirty before though
it looks clean can you get a really nice
closeup of
that this is really amazing stuff do you
like it hairy or hairless well now all
of a sudden I think I might like it
hairless is it safe to cover your whole
body in at once I have only tried it on
like my pubes and my ass so I'm not
really sure if I I'm not supery up here
you can do the whole pubic area I I
wouldn't suggest cuz it burned my penis
oh my god dude it's clean boy this is
like a stunning endorsement for n man it
looks you look good thank you so much I
feel good actually really feel good with
that I think that looks really good it
looks like a dut actually if you see it
from like the camera angle like a Crispy
Cream glazed donut should we like take a
bite or just kidding I'm I'm not kidding
that's vile sorry I put you all through
that well that worked way better than I
thought all right I'm going to do I
shoot this
out that's so gross you guys are
you guys are
nasty I'm going to shoot it to somebody
who wants it I'm going to shoot it you
want it you're so close you're a little
close man you might get nare in your
mouth
stuff that dirty dude in there all right
we're going to stuff that thing
full is this a good idea or no does
anybody even want this shirt not
really Kevin you want to shoot it uh me
oh I mean if you just don't just don't
aim at anyone in the front cuz that
thing is strong as well just just
find someone you like here this guy in
the sweater let's give it to him and the
green sweater is it
charged oh wow oh you poor girl all
right girl we're going to we're going to
need you to sign a release okay and do
not let that get close to your own hair
don't smell wash it first okay all right
well thanks Kev of course thanks so
much for this award thank you I
appreciate it so much that is hard
do I need soap and water or am I cool
that shit's hard so hairy is it burning
I'm like totally shocked by this I am
too I didn't think this work that
good is it is it burning no
what oh there's a share there's a shower
n that is good to know is there there is
there a sensitive nare for the genitals
um yes the ladies are saying
yes I'm going to have to go get me some
wow that was really I feel like
a can I say I feel like a virgin for the
very first
time that's amazing thank you Kev uh
thank you so much thanks so much for
this award everyone and for voting for
me and to anyone that watched me near my
ass in the summer like you guys changed
my life and to the ones that stayed
after to hear me talk about sharding and
doing my dance on Riner doodle D
thank you so much I love you guys thank
you man thank you P thank you so much
that was great that was very fun thank
you man no you're good you're good
you're
good we should made he's a cool dude we
should have made it into
ABS what you can't put the hair back on
too late I'm no I'm happy with this bro
ela's going to get weird with me
later there's you can do so much with
this that might catch on new trend
I'm I'm I'm like frankly I'm a little
speechless by how crazy that is honestly
me too I've never
oh T how did you even request beverage
an alcoholic beverage while how did you
even get this crowd is taking a shot
with me how did you how did she even
order
that you're just speaking telepathically
it's like it's like door Dash but for
the cancel they know you know no one's
paying me to the stage hands were just
like she needs a drink absolutely cheers
to love cheers honor cheers if you can't
come in her come on
[Applause]
her
um unironically this is amazing crowd
you this is nuts thank you guys so much
for being here so crazy thank you guys
really everybody that dressed up you're
looking really good you guys look
phenomenal and I love it thank you guys
really love you all love you buddy
whoever said that love you I don't trust
who's that someone screen do I know who
that is who are you who's that guy wait
Ireland what Jesus man oh my God was
that really the best use of your time
and
money ah happy birthday happy birthday
we love the
Irish sorry about
Bono he's Irish right okay up next we've
got our very own legal analyst you guys
know him you love him it's David from p
and p bring him
out there he
is let's
go they love you man I
love you sorry ladies I met your fiance
backstage
congratulations oh thank you thank you
it's engaged you're good man thank you
so we have we have a let's go let's go
let's
go so we have
um a special category it's called the
where are the police award and you know
every year there's always so much
questionable activities and you say this
has to be
illegal but this year I feel especially
oh yeah so so let's go so uh let's roll
the video disc at David D's house or no
what who who whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa we don't speak that name just
like where are the police you
know hey I was going to before I forget
after this we're going to raid the
pizzeria who's with
me yeah oh you're talking about you you
you're R there I don't know what just
happened forget I you want to RI
at we're going to storm the pizzeria
wait we probably shouldn't say that like
a good neighb some cars and
huh you want to torch some cars and
yeah Cody's here you guys remember
him he'll yeah you guys remember
Cody that's the guy who came to my house
the one that went to his house
yeah I met him backstage this
just brought him here scared the
out of me we're friends Cody where are
you he's scary though for real shout out
to Cody oh Cody coming out oh look
fresh out of prison and he wants to go
back that's Cody
[Applause]
guys all right all right yeah and night
and I then you know I I way I way rather
I like you as my friend way more man
trust me you want to shoot it Show's
awesome guys hey
guys we're allies
now let him use the gun you want to
shoot it and that wasn't him that went
to the house all right just for legal
purposes right
[Music]
lawyer
this isn't the only load he's going to
be shooting out
tonight it's like the Terminator
dude yeah Sho no no no damn it
Cody the only gun he's ever legally shot
everyone
hell wow oh
all right thank you Cody bye please
don't please don't hurt anybody that was
sick's got a good arm he hasn't shot a
gun in like four
hours God a good I'll see you tonight
bro he's a good man and thank you for
bringing him by the way JN I'm so happy
to see you two together you know it's
it's was such a nice surprise thank
three of us coming together but Cody
being here after all the crimes he's
done and haunted your family and he he
really casually pointed that gun at you
man like he didn't he didn't even think
about it it's the only legal gun he's
ever shot
gave you gave him a gun you psycho I
love that that's you know what I know
that was a mistake what Ela sorry you
going to say something Ela no okay give
her apologize on his behalf my favorite
thing about tonight is heila just being
dead silent thank she's protecting her
peace that's my specialty she's
protecting the baby's peace she's just
here and being that hot honestly stand
up can you just can you just show the
audience how H you look one time one
more time stand up for us if you stand
up with me one time I'll stand up with
you I'm so sorry honestly it's just so
hard to hear anybody check this one out
ready no stop it I will get on my knees
and bow down to hila any day no stop
it that's our girl no I actually no idea
what's happening but I think it's cool I
love you
so we're keeping the H3 brand wholesome
okay we're women that's all we can do
give it up arila stop
it ela's here to keep me on the rails
you know she's the H listen age three I
swear to God if you up one time I'm
going to hit on her so crazy really like
I swear to God good job good
job the lawyer the lawyer
yeah you hear that
El I'm just here being silent she say
she can put my belly button on her only
fans you're okay with that no no no but
what if you guys start Jo was it okay
that Cody he's like a is Cody a
felon uh I mean what do you think
probably can he vote uh none of us can
vote
no it who cares we vote for godamn
award you didn't know he was a felon and
it's okay it's okay I didn't know he was
a felon you guys before I gave him the
gun I swear can you get my felonies
expunged what's that can you get my
felonies expunged yeah dude he's the
best he can do
anything the best you will be surprised
what kind of stuff you can get expunged
I just have marijuana
trafficking um cocaine traff I so I have
a few things it's like it's like 10
years ago he can do anything
unironically you guys should actually
talk he's he'll do that he's
crazy got your back I'm voting again
yeah I'm getting my rights back all
right guys let's
uh let's let's roll it with uh where are
the police where are the police
award EDP exposed again the things he's
been sending to this 15-year-old girl I
don't know what the this even
is but he did send that to the girl I
guess he put some eyeliner on and some
lipstick a picture of his uh of his uh
volcano crater of a penis get the
out of here you this is not a
joke man I'm just seld him at a loss for
words you know two years ago you were
caught kiss my ass in 4k trying to meet
a 13-year-old well Brian I just want to
know why do you think we're here
you man James Charles exposed again I
was 16 November 7th 2020
9:24 age check and I responded and I
said I'm a very mature 16 that should
have been end of conversation
um but then he proceeded to add me on
Snapchat this is November 24th I open
this set and I swear to God it was a
full ass thing Colleen Ballinger
inappropriate conduct with miners this
is the woman who we sent back and forth
Trisha P's nuds for funsies whenever I
was like 15 this is the woman that told
me about her sex life when she when I
was like 15 14 Colleen would send us you
know videos with like tampons and stuff
yeah I remember her on a call with me on
Snapchat asking me to buy tampons so I
could put them in my mouth and send her
a video of
it Steven Crowder exposes himself to
employes Steven Crowder allegedly
created an incredibly inappropriate and
hostile workplace where he exposed his
genitals to employes no that doesn't
work
either Logan Paul has still not made
good on crypto Zoo which ultimately
resulted in millions of dollars being
stolen from fans Logan Paul announced a
1.8 million dooll refund to the victims
Logan Paul has not paid back his victims
he hasn't talked about it since he first
announced he was going to pay them back
and what's worst of all he doesn't seem
to have a plan in place to refund anyone
Jack D's bodyguard punch his guy in face
just stop stop
stop oh
oh no yo stop stop wrong with you are
you crazy what's up hey one one
what's up security guard you
you
it is
wow those there's a few of your clients
in there
E look the police need to get their
together cuz it's been a tough year
financially because they've been
sleeping can I ask you a question yeah
is that illegal what the is that
security
I'm Prett I don't know if they can see
it I don't they might need a shot of it
but I love you too though I love you too
it says I love Trisha pis if you guys
can
see she's doing a little gag on me I
mean listen I mean listen I I love her
too we know I want bren's back I know I
want bren's
back I don't I don't I don't want Jeff
Jeff is so happy
can you shut up no look get him
beating me can you put FR ofies
back we'll see I love you both so much
this just what I'll say about Trish I
love you both so much I feel like a
child of divorce parent and I hate it
this what I'll say about
Trisha
no I she's one of the most entertaining
talented entertainers there
are
it's true I mean say what you will but
the shirt looks
amazing that girl can cry on the
bathroom floor like no other true I'm a
chicken nugget I'm a chicken nugget not
best you know I wonder I wonder if
that'll ever happen to us one day we're
we'll have a ter terrible falling out
and we'll hate each other probably
you'll hit me well do either of you have
siblings what do either of you have
siblings uh yes so just don't his
his brother just it you'll be good he
just yelled at me for all of his
best friends so oh uhoh know I don't
think my brother yeah well you don't
care I mean you know I want it to all
work Ethan so here's what I'll say
imagine Trisha pis was on the stage
right now yeah she's not coming out guys
that's on the only fan but I'll say this
I'm very happy uh that she has a
beautiful daughter and she's pregnant
again I wish her all the best with I'm
the Godmother I'm the Godmother of the
new son or daughter I don't
know I'm the Godmother you're the
Godmother and I I love that I'm able to
possess the balance you're the
Godmother I am you have cred how do you
prove that are you just saying that what
was that like on video or something no
I'm saying that okay it's
true I love you and I love Trisha and
you have to possess balance okay all
right
but um yeah congratulations to
her thank you Tana can I just please
just one time get a pink of black screen
back and talk some
one
time I'll join I'll join I'll be the
mediator I'll join no that I never
want to go there again you can be team
Ethan I'll be team Trish and we'll do it
together on a pink and black
screen all right well we we
see can I say before we move on I want
to uh take back what I said earlier
about inside in a riot you know nobody
do anything of that stuff so we're not
riding at do I forget we're live on
we're not riding at David do piz not no
it's a peaceful protest not a riot okay
I got you that wow have a peaceful
protest afterwards dude you better you
better make sure that Cody got the memo
that you are kidding I am you better
make sure that Cody got the memo that
you're kidding yo Cody it was just a
joke for entertainment just he's going
there with Weaponry right now right help
me out
lawyer we love Dave we kid David because
we love him yo back me up bro I got back
no worries all right David go ahead
let's um let's announce the winner and
then we I'd like to ask you some
questions so go ahead there there are
some good ones and I had a hard time
myself choosing
one all right and the winner is James
[Applause]
Charles where are you congratulations
James I'm so proud of you James we have
a whole stack of steamies for him he has
not yet picked them up I'll tell you
this he crushed he got 48% Crowder was
in second place at 133% so James really
stepped it up this year EDP exposed only
11% Colleen 10% Logan crypto zo I mean
that one is really illegal it only got
8% send me an eyeliner you
freak enough about this crypto zo stuff
dude it's played out Jack dh's bodyguard
got 5.9% I mean that guy assaulted on
camera I mean look that that was we
almost witnessed a murder right there I
that guy was dead yeah I mean the guy
bounced right back after I mean but it
look it could take another day for the
Hemorrhage to I could so let me ask you
go down there so James Charles what what
is your thoughts on the legality of what
he's been up
to he he's he's basically
texting how many underage boys now it's
got to be like a faker's dozen look I
mean if it was one person maybe two but
once you got like all these people
coming out of the woodwork saying the
same things and showing text messages
and Snapchat that stuff from years ago
when they're
underage it's not looking too good
but I mean with the right lawyer you
might pull this out honestly your
[Music]
honor I swear my client he he asked for
the age and they sent him a falsified uh
ID he asked for the age I just really
want a pigmented waterline eyeliner you
know I smell me five I smell the
tequila
Tana I recall last time you were on our
show you made a promise to me to
denounce James Charles in all of his
forms I am very happy to be civil and
right now as as you guys see trying to
kids he's trying to kids T oh
no yeah he literally he's trying to
kids bro third row third row can you see
that my water line is really pigmented
black like can you guys see that under
my mascara it's
black it's pigmented no but Tana he's
trying to kids they're still
looking at that shirt I'm not
kids no not you James Charles he's
trying to kids right
now he's in so much Snapchat DM right
now somebody call cops what do you want
me to do
Ethan do you denounce James Charles can
you can you agree that my waterline is
pigmented it black yes your mascara is
running like no that my wing that my
wing is very pronounced what does that
mean well I'm sorry no I don't know what
you're I don't know what that means it's
it's more so just like look at my
waterline in my eye it's black I
literally don't know what you're saying
what hold on hold on you makeup
I guess hold the on hold on oh wait
are you using his makeup God forbid are
you is that what you're trying to say
look cuz you ter that the guys don't
know anything about oh my God God forbid
I talk to men that's horrible let me on
that are trying to
kids I that's not a man all right that
I'll take that as
a what is a man we are we are if you
could denounce something less than civil
that's what I would say so wait where do
you draw the line is it kids are
is is I stopped trying to fist fight him
for five years so it's good that we're
okay riot at James's I'm so sorry have
y'all okay okay no riots let's talk to
the crowd no riots have you ever been
they're turning on you T they're turning
on
you cut cut her off somewh no I have a
question for the
crowd have you ever been so angry at
someone that it consumes your entire
being oh wow a lot of haters in the
audience you guys need to let that
go wonder you guys like this show you
spend a lot of your life at that person
and it does feel good over time to be
like I don't like you we're not going to
talk like we're civil I don't have to
fist fight you at a party hit the button
D
wrong wrong I think that's the truth I
understand no I been I'm pen pal with R
Kelly so I understand where you're
coming from sincerely I I do feel like
I'm pen mouths with ar Kelly yeah every
you know everybody needs a
friend like your makeup line I hope
my tour sells out and you don't sell a
sale but like we can't get along we're
we're fine being civil but for the
record and we'll move
on he dm'd this kid age
check but anyway you want me to say the
p word huh no no no
no no I just want you to say that you
wish you perished in a fire
that's
all I think that so A long time ago when
Trump was going
[Music]
against you look to Tana Mojo for your
advice all right Tana has no opinions
she doesn't know nothing about nobody I
don't know where I am right now bab I
think I'm at EC you're making Logan look
like an angel right now Logan will you
denounce James Charles and all of his
forms if he's ding children like that
then yeah yeah and he is there you go
you see that's right Logan Paul everyone
dude Logan Paul you're the coolest bro
we love Logan protect our kids bro I'm a
I love Logan Paul just don't drink Prime
energy if you're under the age of
12 but you could James Charles all
right so canot Prime do you think James
Charles is doing anything
illegal yeah for sure
so what would it be like solic you can't
look he knows what he's doing and I
think at this point the evidence is
pretty
overwhelming and I mean a prosecutor
should pick this up that's what I think
where's the police literally
look look I I want to announce you guys
in trouble I'm in trouble I really I am
calling on the United States Congress to
enact legislation to make a DA's office
that prosecutes YouTube crimes and
they'd be busy and I will run for that
DA's
office YouTube crimes division of the
FBI coming it's coming all right so
James is doing a Crowder he let's
see Crowder well he did show his
genitals un to unwilling uh viewers in
his workplace that sounds illegal right
yeah no that he could have to register
for life for that that's a sex offender
thing was he but was it like a joke kind
of like it was a joke but nobody asked
he's like hey guys here's my dick that's
pretty funny though that's it's funny it
is funny was it just the guys or was
just the Bros that's fine that's funny
then that's good it's fine just the Bros
we've James Charles there's a pattern
here what LO I said we've all seen your
podcast okay we're good I mean I've seen
who was that that fit that thing in the
cup I mean that was so small you talk
about my yeah your bro my belly button
no I have a story about I have not shown
my dick on the podcast just for the
record no not you thank
you oh
seean okay so anyway uh Crowder so he
EDP I mean that's Nob brainer uh you
know about his story right oh yeah that
was really bad he went back for
seconds and it was an actual
kid yeah it was it she was like I don't
know how old was the girl I mean I don't
know like 14 or something oh brother
Colleen that's an interesting one are
you up to date with that I'm not too up
to date but from what I've seen it's
pretty bad I would say that she was you
know not as bad as James Charles but up
there right he should be an easy one
like where is the police man
yeah I know listen I've been let sit
down I'm Get Up Stand Up
Jeff stand
up I've been around a lot of bad guys in
my life you know spend time with some
locked up in a cage and even those
pieces of murders do not
tolerate touching kids
right now I know my co-host here will
add a little too much
tequila so I'm going to apologize for
her she does not support any pet can I
say the word you can say the word she
does not support any pedophiles okay she
does
not kids is
bad we don't support it obiously I don't
support that what the I'm
trying to be civil that's right right
that's right shut the up shut
the yeah you know uh Al-Qaeda is joining
me for dinner this Sunday I like to keep
it
civil we're tired just keeping the
peace um crypto Zoo that's crazy right
that one's just straight up fraud that
is straight up fraud and it was an
accident it was a it was Logan I mean
what man you should be in jail brother
look hold on hold on Got to Believe In
the concept the underlying principle was
fire okay those little eggs that you'd
collect and then you'd sit on that egg
for I me oh my God it was cool the
little the little crit fun game it's a
fun game Sil it's a fun game that taught
the kids of our youth how to invest
properly okay we needed just strategize
rethink our Formula 2 I'm going to kill
myself okay look hold on hold on hold on
Sude references counter what is that
the in defense of my uh unofficial
client here
uh maybe he didn't really know about the
fraud but somebody in that organization
knew what was going on in millions of
dollars that's right that's right that's
what he told me that's I apologize for
hiring criminals but that is the only
thing I am sorry for
okay he's a good guy he's he didn't know
he didn't know he's a good guy yeah and
the final one is the jack dority one
which I think like you said that was
attempted murder I feel like yeah
security guard is huge that was at least
assault with a deadly weapon being he's
so big I've got a trial on this I'm
telling you on whose side
uh I mean on the defense side the person
that tried to kill them yeah awesome did
you get them off yeah hell yeah they're
back out there on the street people hold
8 8 years jail we did a plead deal to 10
days jail but we got to choose on which
weekends he could do one day here one
day there no shot David Works magic
people
there's nobody like him let's go let's
go
go all right well David I'm sure you're
very busy freeing the rkm Asylum of all
the uh the super villains so we'll let
you to that but thank you for coming and
we love you so much I'll DM you bro
thank you guys thank you I love you guys
let's
go love you budy thank
you thanks bro love you
bro all right David wow what a guy how
you the crew doing I haven't heard from
you guys where is everybody oh yeah me I
noticed like 5 minutes ago everyone's
gone I don't know I'm supposed
to what happened I don't know maybe are
they are they Pro is this a walk out I I
don't know maybe I are they finally
unionizing they are starting the protest
at David docks they've left they're on
their way to dricks no don't do that
what don't do
that friend me friend
it works it
works you guys can't hear it the ab's
mic I'm hearing reports that it's uh go
ahead
hello there we go thank you thank you
yeah I was just saying I like 5 minutes
ago I looked around and realized
everyone's gone am I supposed to still
be sitting here I don't know that's
messed up they just bailed on you they
bailed on me yeah friends like these huh
you know what that means bro that means
you're a scab and I love you for
that
bro I'm not going to make you feel alone
I'll come over here bro's it going oh
I think you dropped your you VAP
bro you dropped your Vape you dropped
your vapeo oh my God bro you dropped
your Vape bro that's not
mine true I don't know who it was anyway
Dan how are we doing on time do I need
to like are we good no we're doing
horrible we're about 30 minutes behind
oh
absolutely Terri we're having too
much fun I got to I got to slam through
these yep all right next up friend of
the show enemy of the show actually won
an award earlier friend ofy of the show
fremy of the show freemies worst kick
platform moment presented by X
QC yo dude what's up dude what up what
what up y yo yo yo
yo excuse the
WW let's go Che this
out check this out dude I got my whole
my your your whole your whole house my I
got your whole house on my wrist dude
let's go you see this hell yeah
D what did you say in my DM huh what did
you say in my DMs again I can't hear you
what did you say in your DM d m you
you've been in Tana's DMS oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all the done
yeah I know all about
that got to shoot half the audience what
I probably sent you a picture of his
watch what probably sent you a picture
of his watch all right moving on moving
on so um go ahead and roll the video
please the DM apple apple oh good apple
oh thanks man
moment Aiden Ross streams the Super Bowl
um I'm going to be doing Omega watching
live sports he went and he went over
there after his big stream on Twitch uh
and then he started reacting to uh the
superow live with 66,000 viewers you
have you are you guys allowed to talk on
no comment TR uh that's my lawyer so he
can he can
uh yeah the watching of anything will
not be tolerated dmca laws do exist and
they will be enforced so have that
common sense if it's ever happened
that's as much as I can give you there's
no terms of service over there Jack Dar
body guard punches guy in face
one
oh oh no yo stop stop wrong with you are
you what's up hey what up
security are you
excuse see
streams and I said yo bro let's hang out
a makes
sense v um V friends GG's okay I don't
think it's a troll is it no it's
not Aiden Ross shows porn to his
audience doing unlimit we can literally
watch porn together I could jerk off
what do y'all want to watch bro I don't
support porn like I don't I don't
support this the do yall want
to watch watch on here bro I don't
support this I don't condone it I
don't support it there's no way
what you're just having this on stream
is that bad what ice Poseidon pays a
prostitute on
stream yeah it is extra 100 for filming
now hey have money
back definitely cannot hold the door I
was about to fly out of the room and
just try to Res resolve everything your
wife currently under arrest for sexual
assault
seriously kick staff supports fy's
mental breakdown there's a gun to my
head right now there's a gun to my head
help ma'am ma' ma'am ma'am
InterContinental what's my room number
help tell me
2027 that's what I have to do to get
help are y'all dumb or are you stupid
free the G7 president you listen we'll
just discuss that before we we we listen
we I think we've all unanimously agreed
it's about high time that we you know he
he's he's let go I reckon we need a lot
of our brave Florida based kick members
to to to line up outside this this
facility of such that he's in and uh
break in or free him or or or devise
some plan to get this guy
out K has had quite a year really that's
awesome impressive uh impressive really
yeah very impressive so go ahead I'm
done with this this here we go there we
go it's actually love me no way oh my
God I loved it yo all right are we ready
for the go ahead please all right so
let's see here the winner
for the worst cake form platform uh cake
platform moment is Aden Ross show
porn
[Applause]
congratulations man you
know I'm so happy that there's a
breakaway platform where
yeah adults can show porn to kids as
they wish in fact where's James Charles
on that
thank you love thank you all right
we got to keep it going
[Applause]
um what happened you hit that Vape no
nobody wanted that
wig you're the man
Logan something's supposed to
happen
[Applause]
gab where are
you is that Gabe up
there
[Music]
[Applause]
game is that you all the way up in the
balcony I can't see you there's no
lights there's no lights for me to see
and the dark dark
balcony we working on it all
right we can hear you which is great we
love that we love that we can hear you
but to see you really would be
the best part of this bit that we try
looking
harder who the is Uncle Gabe who
the is Uncle Gabe
[Applause]
[Music]
who all right all right
okay all
right
[Music]
wheel The Joker got away hey jingle
bells Batman spells Robin
L Batmobile loes and the Joker got away
all right thank
you for that impromptu
song so are we going to do this stare
off I I'm confused
now know do that
[Applause]
part
[Music]
[Applause]
he
Uncle Gabe
everybody love you
buddy a special moment I love you Ethan
love you buddy you're the best what
other show would bring uh 3,500 people
to watch silence for a minute nobody
nobody's that brave no body's doing what
we're
doing all right let's keep it moving
folks I wasn't going to lose to him not
in front of my
people I would have stood here all day
all right up next we've got Dan's
presenting
yes what happened the
first that's actually hold on strike
that we're going to move back one step
uh no that's not what's happening at
this moment what's happening is you guys
remember the
um what's his name the Jersey law
man the Jersey law man the guy who made
the um the dream remix nightmare he won
the tournament the dude who lives in the
UK well he flew out here to perform it
live with
Z the Jersey law man all the way from
[Applause]
[Music]
UK the
cage call me P me up by the roots
we you
[Music]
keep
nightmare
nightm
[Music]
nightm take my hand
understand when you're
there there
I can't see it's a
nightmare
[Music]
[Applause]
nightm
[Music]
woo
[Applause]
wow I can't Brea when you're not
a
[Music]
nightm
the Jersey law
man
[Music]
yes you're the King of New Jersey bro
yes well done sir you know what we had
the flying in all the way from UK to
prove he actually played that
solo you shredded you dude you
rule man so talented that was awesome
that was very impr
bro I unironically love that
song that's such a good song I love it
and it's on iTunes for 99 since I own
the rights to it so you guys can pick it
up there I own
it and I will be filing I am litigious
let it be known if anyone tries to
publish a similar song in the near
future I will
soon all right up next we've got doxer
of the Year presented by our very own
dance
[Applause]
wor there he
is
hello
everyone Jesus they love you D what the
right yeah they love you okay yeah
yeah oh my
God it's Dan
s it's
Dan loud W Dan when d
you very loud in
here thank you thank you enough thank
you thank you wow what a that was
incredible uh what a greeting thank you
all for being
here you all look amazing tonight thank
you for uh dressing up
um thank
you so I'm here uh to present the award
for doxer of the year what a year it's
been for doxing am I right I
mean maybe 2017 came close but I I don't
really know so um let's take a look at
the nominees and uh and then we'll uh
take a look who
won doxer of the Year Ethan Klein leaks
his emails I'll check my email right now
God there's some weird emails in
here
what you guys are telling me to stop
what chewing or messaging is it the
chewing oh my God I'm
sorry all right T Mojo Do's the wine
tour guy I'm actually going to be
calling her by her name oh is she
horrible Cynthia is that Cynthia Cynthia
Cynthia
Cynthia Cynthia I put in my my
headphones and she says can you please
take your headphones out I don't want to
learn about fertilization of grass in
the middle of France in a town of a
population of 300 at 8:34 a.m. after
I've just walked a mile and a half and
there's yet to be a glass of wine in my
hand since Tana made this guide's name
and workplace public of course Tana's
fans found the business and they started
to leave a ton of negative reviews Ethan
Clin shows his credit card did I I
didn't show my car did I hold on hold on
did I show my car how' you guys see that
there's no way you could read that right
why why did I do that Dylan pige doxes
the plain lady that back there is not
real she has officially been identified
as Tiffany she is 38 years old and the
founder of a in called according to
public records Tiffany is a graduate of
State University and lives in a $2
million home in the neighborhood of
Ethan Clin leaks Love's phone
[Music]
[Applause]
number I don't I hope I didn't play
long how many numbers did I show or did
I do was it no way Sniper Wolf goes to
Jack film's house they're posting an
Instagram story with a poll saying
should I visit ja's films he lives 5
minutes away from my shoe all right
right in front of your house come out
come out and talk to me he has food
outside so he should be out any minute
now to pick it up I just want to talk
she's literally right outside oh my God
this is happening right now call
the police
wait what last night Sniper Wolf
a massive YouTuber showed up outside of
our home recorded a video of our home
and then posted it to her 5.6 million
Instagram followers Ethan Klein leaks
his own phone number I showed my phone
number on the screen twice one was Dan's
fa twice was Dan's fall n yeah this is
Ethan you're calling my personal number
so what do you want no hey I'm so sorry
for calling now I feel like so I really
but hey I'm s I'm sorry please don't
call me anymore sorry all right
bye
wow wow well it's got to be a shoe in
for Sniper Wolf so Sniper Wolf I mean
she's got to be the favorite obviously
but that was crazy what she did but just
by sheer volume Ethan that was all
within like a month too I was frankly
50% of all the uh n
that was crazy all right well um let's
take a look at who the big winner
is you ready TNA do you want this one or
no I believe in you I really don't want
it you don't want this one all right
well the winner
is please don't be
me it's a sweep Ethan Klein
[Applause]
[Music]
what
you did it buddy you did
it all right first C I just say thank
you D first of all there's no
way that I beat Sniper Wolf what is
wrong with y'all he showed up in his fre
although yeah sorry love by the way I do
apologize for that it wasn't I did have
a big year for
doxing I did vote for you you did yeah I
don't blame you for that but you guys
come on
someone called me this morning I kid you
oh she has my credit card hell yeah yeah
yeah all right well I'll talk to you
guys later y'all give me a text later
tonight I'll I'll talk to youall then
you can also call me if you want thank
you the real honor I think
wow and just to
uh just to uh cap this off Ethan took a
56.8% of the vote uh between all four
Sniper Wolf was the number one
individual
with 36.6% of the
[Applause]
vote oh
nice that was a good one
czy all right we got to keep the show on
the road so I'm going to go see you
everybody bye thank you
Dan all right next category is worst
debater and we've had a really nice year
of debates I think and and so there's
frankly a lot of good uh nominees here
so let's go ahead and roll we have a
special forward though from a guest so
let's let's listen to that hey everyone
I hope you're doing well and Merry
Christmas to you all I just want to say
good luck to the debate nominees you've
all been fantastic uh sharing your views
on different topics it's so important to
have a debate so I'm so proud of all of
you guys nominees you're going to rock
it I know you're going to win and I
should totally be winning this debate
because as you guys know I'm always
debating
at least give me second place right guys
debating is so important so you guys are
going to win alongside me bye Wow first
debat olle
London if you go to your website you are
actually selling kids lunchboxes with a
picture of you depicted as a trans woman
that's not a trans woman that's not a
trans woman that's just a K-pop picture
of me here it is you wearing that Design
This is depicting you and this is when
you were TR correct at the time I was a
transwoman but that picture does not
depict me as a transwoman it depicts me
as a K-pop Star but I find that
interesting that you're willing to uh
make that separation when you're making
such General claims about uh groomers
and stuff because to me by your own
definition this is pretty groomy just
pearly things do you agree with that
premise that slavery was embellished or
no um I think that there are parts that
are under embellished and there are
parts that are over embellished I think
it just depends what we're talking about
so interesting I've got to know what was
over ellish about slavery just like one
example I'm dying to
know yeah I just I just rather I mean I
was talking about a book that I read you
just said some parts were embellished
some parts were under embellished I I
just are you retracting that I just I
I'd really just rather not just say I
don't think slavery was embellished I
mean that's super easy that's like a
layup just say you don't think slavery
was embellished I think there are
certain facts that you're not allowed to
talk about I don't really want to talk
about it Mark Elliot for for anyone
who's listening that wants to find out
more they can go to make Justice
blind.com and they can look at the
evidence with respect with respect to
the FBI you what I've been talking about
here this this is the video right uh
evidence of historic corruption this is
the one you're talking could we at least
could we at least this is one of the
guys is Alan
dtz he
represented he's Epstein's
lawyer could we play it from the
beginning few minutes let's you know
what I'll do you know
what I'll do that for
yous waiting this they should take
immediate action and if they can't or
they won't United States Attorney
General should independent prut the
video that you saw with these experts
these are serious serious things that
we're talking about do you want to give
a closing statement or anything they're
just putting things on the screen no
that helps people's attention spam cuz
it's a little boring so it's a little
dense so sometimes you put kinetic sand
or Subway Surfer it makes it easier to
listen gotcha
Sebastian I don't think people are born
gay yeah I think that they it's a choice
the amount of left-handed people back in
the day was really low because people
with left-handed were seen as inferior
but as it became more acceptable and
people realized left-handed people
weren't demons then the amount of
left-handed people increased would you
say people choose to be left-handed uh I
don't know do you choose day to have to
be attracted to women no I wouldn't say
so I'm just naturally attracted to women
right so do I need to connect the dots
or you got
it let me think about it hold on I
excuse me when you go on these tangents
you just you go on a rampage you just
ramble and ramble without making any
concise point or a question I think this
conversation is kind of been exhausted
people would rather watch me full screen
cam do the warm Prime bro for a
week do a week of no reaction content
and see how many views you get
oh he's crying in the
corner oh okay sure I mean that's
content man it's it's original content
at least
yes do that
bro
wow that's a lot of fun frankly um
well and by the way Oli London totally
willingly made us that video with full
knowledge of uh what he was talking
about we love you OE thank you for that
we don't love Olli that guy
sucks he's the worst actually it's a
groomer too see that lunch
box all right worst debater let's open
this
up and the winner is little bathroom
break sorry we love that how was it good
so good nice nice and the winner is with
43% of the vote
Pearl
congratulations girl slavery was
embellished you heard it from her
beautiful that's awesome that she said
that yeah she I mean she she definitely
it was a great year for debates though
really I mean thank you to everybody so
congratulations Pearl um very good thank
you all right up next here's somebody
that you guys might love almost as much
as I do
she frankly gave birth to
me she literally birthed
me talking of
course about da
[Applause]
Cline there she is
I hope there's some Dawn ARS out
[Applause]
there so before I read um the top four
internet uh nominees for drama for 2023
I just like to respond to T's
suggestion I think we love Tanya you
corrector or no I think we'd be better
off bringing back
[Applause]
families bro I love your jacket look at
this it's
awesome sick so should we watch the
videos so we are doing spiciest drama so
let's go ahead spiciest
drama Ariana Grande dates sponge B
Square Pants news broke about Ariana and
her husband doton Gomez's separation
followed by rumors of her dating her
Wicked co-star Ethan Slater Ethan had a
wife and child with said wife and a lot
of people are speculating about possible
overlap Ethan and Lily have been
together for over 10 years and they
welcome their first child together only
in 2022 Ethan Slater has officially
filed for divorce from his wife Lily Jay
Lily has finally spoken out herself
Ariana's the story really not a girl
scroll my family is just collateral
damage Sniper Wolf dox's Jack films this
Sniper Wolf situation is disgusting it
is reckless it is dangerous but they're
posting an Instagram story with a poll
saying should I visit Jack films he
lives 5 minutes away from my shoot and
as it turns out she wasn't joking
because she ended up posting from
outside his house in my 17 years on
YouTube I've never once had someone come
to my home and vaguely threaten me
Sniper Wolf needs to be
deplatformed Colleen Ballinger exposed
by half the inter youve never been to a
Miranda show Colleen frequently has
segments where she calls people up on
stage I got called up for the yoga
challenge I am laying down and Colleen
is spreading my legs basically as far as
she can smirking down at me while
thousands of people were laughing and I
was terrified that my body wasn't
covered enough I was about 16 we sent
back back and forth Trisha Pet's nudes
for funsies whenever I was like 15 using
someone's nudes as
[Music]
other is the lowest form of human the
lowest form of intelligence I think
that's so inhumane I think that's so
disgusting for anyone when I walked
through those doors it red of alcohol
and cigarettes and no one was there and
then I went upstairs and she was sitting
on our bed
playing her
you Logan Paul vers Dyan Dennis the
judge has now approved Nina agdal's
restraining order against Dylan Dan
Logan Paul and Dylan are scheduled to
fight each other to repeatedly harass
and shame Logan's fiance Nina the
restraining order is now in full effect
I'm a profit server yes I got him taken
sir why won't you pay back to people
from crypto Zoo I'm working on it Dylan
you scammed your audience 20 times
Rosanna Pano says Mr Beast rigs his
videos Pano came out to talk about how
Mr Beast lied in a video he posted last
year titled extreme $1 million hide and
seek top three winners were Logan Paul L
Reay and Zach K Rosanna says that isn't
what happened in real life I have been
allowing others to treat me poorly in
private for many years and I'm fed up Mr
Beast lien edited me out of the top
three in creator games 3 did you decide
to break the NDA by coming out or was
there some kind of legal clarification
you got on it we'll see and then shortly
after this she deleted all her tweets
and made an apology to Mr Beast where
she said I would like to apologize to Mr
Beast a couple days later Rosanna then
goes back on her previous retraction by
saying I redact my apology to Mr Beast
of not settling things
[Music]
privately wow well the the reason I have
my mom here is because she actually has
a PhD
and decoding drama so if you could
please just for all of us in the crowd
who may not be fully brushed up if you
could just give us a in a nutshell what
each one of these things
is you know that you asked me to look
into all of this and it was all Greek to
me but I did my best you have you have
flash cards what's that you have flash
cards I do I you know me and my
notes
the first nominee was uh Colleen
Bellinger by enlisting then manipulating
her young subscribers colen um Colleen
Bamboozled them into doing her bidding
which was digging up dirt on her fellow
internet creators finally blam shifting
her uh foot soldiers leaving them to
take all the heat I like that you said
Bamboozled that doesn't sound like a
crime when you put it that way she's
like yeah I B I just Bamboozled them
it's a little
Bamboozled um our second best drama
nominee goes to Sniper Wolf versus Jack
films Jack films calls out Sniper Wolf
stealing Tick Tock slash uh internet
content from other creators material
without even trans being transformative
or giving credit to its creators that
doesn't seem like fair use to me no it
doesn't
not only that giving out his address is
doxing and outright dangerous you know
we were swatted and it's very dangerous
you
can't you see hey Sniper Wolf I hope
you're watching that
our third nominee goes to Ariana
Grande and her new boyfriend Ethan
Slater for having a Broadway show
romance giving up their commitment and
loyalty to their own spouses you know
I'm kind of oldfashioned but you know
whatever happened to till death do us
part
right wow so so
traditional we love monogamy don't we
folks we do we do and our last but not
least drama nominee goes to Logan Paul
there's your boy right
there for making false promises is
misleading fans that were duped into
spending millions of dollars on your
crypto I pref the word Bamboozled from
now on though okay what do you have to
say for yourself buddy I think enough
has been said on
this I love you
all I can see why I I can see where
Ethan gets his good looks from oh thank
you well you know millions of dollars
were lost
um in exchange for that crypto Zoo
currency I'm still working on it okay
I'm still working on it give me time
2024 it was needed to play that game
that never
worked dude you just got toasted
finally finally
Logan abandoned his scheme this scheme
of his much like his abandoned project
dink
donk
she hit you with the dto
bro why Play the song play the song to
say left me speechless right there
that's all I have to say is fool me once
shame on you fool me twice shame on me
oh so so that I mean that kind of
defends him a little bit that's like yo
you crypto Zoo shame on
you bamboozled I'm sorry thank you man
so now I get to read the uh win thank
you that was a really nice um summary
thank you what a crow you guys are
beautiful God look at how many people
let's go ahead and uh Crown the winner
okay if I can get it out of the
envelope okay oh there's percentages too
okay number one special drama goes to
Colleen
Bellinger by half the internet it was
her year
67.9% 67
7.9% Colleen we see you girl this is
your year wow Ariana Grande dates
SpongeBob
17.7% Sniper Wolf versus Jack films
10.2% Rosanna versus Mr Beast two
2% and Logan and Nina versus Dylan danis
1.2% there it is there you have
it thank you Mom well done thank you you
know it's a shame that um we don't have
anything for Dad I mean you're here
and we like we like we love my mom but
my dad always has some fun contributions
to the show too and I just wish that we
had uh something more for him
what
what what is it uhoh holy is that a
14t beach ball
[Applause]
goad your dad in the beach oh my God
excuse me excuse
me if only there was
someone oh my God it's my dad with a
samurai
[Applause]
sword
wa
still got air in
it still got air in it there it
is just think of all the Dodger games
you've had uh messed
up think of all the waves and the beach
balls that have ruined the Dodger games
for you smash smash all right thank you
[Music]
Dad I'm so glad we had the the perfect
man for the
J Bye Mom love you thank
you that was
great so convenient that he was there
with the samurai sword that was so nice
thank you all right so up next there's a
quick this is more of a kind of a
special category I'm going to go up to
the podium for
it
dude and brothers I'll tell let me tell
you this nobody has there's a line
outside their store I don't know if you
guys saw that like holy they have
good chocolate they have good chocolate
did you try it did you like it it's good
right yeah we love him Jeff is a good
guy any who so typically at award shows
there's a once in a time once in a
lifetime kind of
excellence and you want to honor these
people with achieve an achievement award
but we're doing it a little differently
here today we're doing the uh lifetime
lack of Achievement Award
yeah um so let's go ahead and roll the
nominees lifetime lack of Achievement
Award Ryan
Kavanaugh T is a force of nature onto
himself he's involved in more movies
than any single human being he and his
team have picked great films they've
done very well they've been a success
Against All Odds in me you know they've
revolutionized our industry and I for
one I'm thrilled to be in business with
him and even more important I'm thrilled
to be his friend I get to Star and live
professional too and have an
inappropriate relationship with a
14-year-old Natalie Portman so that's
the only reason I came here I'm just
joking too much wine sorry um I'm
thrilled to announce that our building a
Greater Los campaign has its first $1
million donation from an
individual this gentleman is Mr Ryan
Kavanagh not only is Ryan giving us $1
million but he has agreed to be the
chair of the campaign and on behalf of
the city of Los Angeles Ryan we thank
you so much for being a million dooll
donor to Habitat Mandy you're going to
make Los Angeles a better place to live
for so many people thank
you
so if you don't have naysayers and this
is what we talk about all the time then
we should be worried because then we're
not actually doing anything original or
different so I kind of encourage the
naysayers and you know please keep
naysaying why are you suing me
continuing to challenge the status quo
which threatens small minds I decided to
do failure I have failed a lot and not
only have I failed a lot not infinite
but exponential failures that's what
I've done the most I have failed and
failed and failed failed I've
wanted to give up failure is for me we
all fail and we fail over and over and
over again my job is failure oh yeah
that's
awesome oh God man oh it's just one
nominee just one okay I'll open the
envelope let's see lifetime lack of
achievement War goes to with
98.3% Ryan kavanov
wow and he's here to accept
no he's
not come on out bro he's he are SVP
actually no I have a special honor to
present to
him as you guys know Ryan Kavanagh
donated $1 million to Habitat for
Humanity and I am here to donate another
$1 million on behalf of Ryan
Kavanaugh to Habitat for Humanity and
now he can say he's donated $2 million
and I will be donating as much as he did
in reality minus 30,000 so nothing it's
nothing thank you Sam congratulations
Ryan Habitat for Humanity is the real
winner folks are we doing crypto next
what's that you got one of those for me
a giant check do you sure yeah for
crypto Zoo well that you're the one
supposed to be handing out the checks
man I'm working on I thought I had to
figure it out you be handing out giant
checks hold on um craigsm is
a holiday tradition that we
love we do and we thought you know we
love our fans so much this year we said
let's bring craigsm to the people and
that is why our
dear
Ian the salaried
[Applause]
employee Ian
I'm ready I'm ready oh come on out buddy
thank
you oh hey how you
[Applause]
doing
I ho ho ho ho ho ho all right how we
doing how we doing tonight we're doing
so good aren't we people we're
fantastic Ethan did you forget my last
name for a second
said Slater no well I I want the uh the
salary
employ okay so I got a bunch of Craigs
men's gifts normally I give them the
crew but the H3 podcast audience is the
nicest most kind people who have never
done anything wrong
ever and make sure you guys write how
much you like me okay don't write
anything
else okay thank you oh good we're good
thank you little couple distractions
there thank you all right first thing
first first thing Santa's had a little
too much eggnog okay I need an empty
seat empty right here fantastic could to
be more
convenient Ethan
I I feel like you need a little you know
guidance little eyes watching over you
here so I got
this to watch over you oh come on J
shete see that there hold up that's all
yours that's
yours as you can see it says always
watching with those beautiful eyes and
these are all of his uh streamy Awards
that's right yes them yeah all the
ones so close we almost had him next
year
okay he is so beautiful those eyes are
something man stunning he's he's stun
okay I got a bunch of gifts to give to
you guys here so let's see what we got
what do we got here all right first up
Logan you're going to like this you're
going to love this one does anyone here
have a crypto wallet crypto
wallet you don't that was a false alarm
false okay crypto wallet crypto wallet
you do wow right behind the shete so
convenient okay go ahead and pop that
open for me there you
go all right you're going to love it
unwrapping the anticipation okay now why
don't you uh read what oh it looks like
this is going to be the certificate of
ownership the H3 podcast 10 million
shares of crypto zoo let's go
go let's go 10 million shares of crypto
Zoo now the exchange rate on that is
about
$684 we're rounding up to seven what's
that Logan we're rounding up to seven $7
according to Logan got to believe in
we're working on it
yeah so hit me up after the show I got
to go get some cash that's going to be
worth a lot of money someday soon know
one man's trash is another man's
treasure we're really putting that to
the test tonight people okay did anybody
have trouble finding the venue
tonight you you had a little trouble got
a little bit okay so why don't you why
don't you pop that open for me and this
is going to help you
out okay
so sniper w W live reaction that's a
Garmin GPS system so whenever you're
navigating Sniper Wolf is always
watching where you're going that's a
really good reaction she's really good
appreciate her so much she's so watchful
she's like Santa Claus it's
incredible okay what else we got so much
okay who here is a big excc juicer fan I
saw your hand first okay I'm walking a
little bit
I'm walk big xqc you're quick you're
very fast okay hold on hold on right
here all right you love
xqc well oh well I'm going to take it
back do you love xqc sure do you love
okay pop that open that's great that's
good
enough okay so there you have the twitch
just chatting the best reacts Felix xcut
Volume
2 okay now featuring Mr chair this this
is incredible you're going to have all
of the best xtt reactions all the best
gambling all the good stuff uh we
actually have a sample video what you'll
find on that DVD if we what you're
looking at is considered the most
densely populated place that ever
existed on an area of just 6.5 Acres or
four football fields dozens of
individual buildings have merged
in
allowed various
work that was it that was 10 minutes of
silence we love that that's definitely
fair
use fantastic hi guys hi hi okay anyone
over here who is oh you're overing it I
haven't said anything slow down you guys
are so excited um now this is a historic
piece of merchandise okay anybody here
love
triller you're all lying you're all
lying okay I'll you know what there you
go pop that open that's very
rare to pute trust
me okay these are
triller Jake Paul training camp pants
problematic okay read what it says right
on the ass
right
Jake Paul vers Ben Asin April 17th
2021 that's the fight that got Ethan
sued four times it's four right four yes
four count them boom boom boom so those
I found those at the thrift store that's
an authentic find right there that's
real they got the tag on them still
there you go 20 bucks that's only going
to Value trust
me oh God how much crap do I have Jesus
where my my bag I lost my bag once again
the eggn man okay all right we got a
couple more things and I'll get out of
your hair here let's see all right after
that let's
see uh okay now this I almost gave this
to
Olivia there you yes almost I'll give
you the next one I'm looking for a a
fallen fan a former fan of one Colleen
Ballinger
anybody I saw your hand very fast okay
very fast okay pop that
open this exciting stuff tell me what
that is oh my gosh haters back
home yes signed by Miranda sings I had
Olivia authenticate the signature she
tells me it's real I see
you that is on discount haters back off
probably should say miners back off I
think but that's a different show
okay it's an old timey joke hey all
right let's see okay this who is a fan
of
dream dream Dre you know what okay I saw
you I saw you wait let's do this here
now this Kus was a little like this year
so I had to I had to put something in
myself I'm a bit of an artist so I
decided to to try and capture the beauty
the emotion behind dream's eyes if you
can show that to the
camera beautiful gorgeous Mass that's a
painting of
dream that's only going to gain value
it's going right to the
MMA thank you thank you I got two more
things all
right maybe let's let's
gobe someone up
front Okay does anybody have a niece a
nephew a little brother a little sister
you do how old are they um one is three
and one is 18 months okay that's perfect
okay why don't you pop that open right
there there you go and if you could show
it to the camera there it's kind
of okay that is a kick slots category
mini slot
machine says give us your money mom
won't notice the credit card is missing
even Drake thinks it's cool what are you
waiting for and unfortunately every spin
is going to be an L unfortunately you
will lose every time unfortunately but
it's good to get them in young get them
used to it so enjoy that okay this is
the last
item
okay who okay who here traveled from a
very far distance far far okay uh let's
see let's see see very far very far
let's
see
how from Sweden from
[Music]
Sweden wow it says straight out of
junop that's right wait you're from y
Shing what let's Che cheers
that's sick this is an incredible moment
okay this is for you then my
friend now this this is going to be I
I'm giving this to you because I want to
see you bring this through
TSA this is from our own Sam Temple this
is a resin Mr Beast
Burger thank you so
much that is a bio weapon my friend be
careful with that don't let it out wow
and there you go ladies and gentlemen
this has been Craigs Miss ho ho ho thank
you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm going
to go get some more eggon thank you very
much cheers thank you thank you wow
thank
you yeah you know I I'm jealous man I
wanted that that's the last Beast
Burger it's been immortalized like Han
Solo is that good one eie is he here
thank you we love you don't we that was
such a fantastic a Craigs a Craigs Miss
Miracle all right let's keep it rolling
up next
[Music]
[Applause]
H okay let's not get ahead of
ourselves so um up next we have a
special message from someone we've been
trying trying trying to get in touch
with for so long he's such a special
soul and we love him so much here's a
special message from our very own
[Applause]
un hello to all VI of the S3 podcast and
the team I am
Anan and pleased to make this GI to wish
a happy Christmas to all viewers of the
St
podcast thank you for your support
kindness love and encouragement that are
of given throughout the years I would
like to share with you on the color of
the most meaningful Christmas song that
I love the most Christ help creates a
beautiful Society with kindness
generosity given happiness and
encouraging each other as a gift to this
world and every human being on
Earth each small H Rejoice together it
is a great power that will clear the
world where we can live in happiness and
Lasting
PE mirac Christmas happy holiday I love
[Applause]
[Music]
you
es everybody
[Music]
know
with
[Music]
GL
Christmas
[Music]
a
and
[Music]
that and that my friends is the sound of
roasting chestnuts well done that you
shred bro that was awesome yeah I
love you ANUK wherever you are we love
you man we tried to get him out here but
he wasn't he wouldn't he wouldn't have
he's not ready he's not he's not show
ready yet but working on it all right
let's move it on Dan how we doing on
time were you catching up we actually
are we're we're making a good time yeah
so should I go slower uh no please cuz I
can I cuz we can chat I've been wanting
to chat with my how you guys doing we're
we have they cut our mics I think I
thought they cut our mics because of
what was going on over here before what
happened I thought they cut our mics
because of uh you know but it's going to
be back what happened and we're back
we're back baby
we're back what a great show so far
shout out to the crew this is incredible
and it wouldn't be possible without you
guys yeah there's people up there and
the people at home stop being mean to T
on Twitter cuz you got in your head oh
no people are being nasty no I'm well
aware of the fact that sometimes I need
to shut the up well I girl I know
that better than anyone you know what I
mean that's what H3 is here for was it
the James Charles stuff I'm not sure I
think it was a lot of all it was all of
it it was all of it it was everything I
think we love all of it that's why we
love you I think the audience brought me
here to Humble me what you brought me
here to Humble me and I need that
sometimes and that's why I love the H3
audience thank you for coming we love
you shout out
ubbs yeah we love you Tana I do
genuinely and Logan Paul I mean wow
you're the best man I just think you're
so you're so cool dude D I love
you bro bro I love this guy man
I had you so wrong not as much as I love
you bro Mike actually just called me and
he was like yo Logan's pissed I was like
what are you talking about he's right
next to me I'm happy as can be did he
say that for
real what is L my God Logan are you
watching right now why are you angry
man oh my God the solution's simple just
give back the
money
you can't resurrect the animals that
died
but hey that pig deserved to Die the pig
the pig lived it was a joke a joke it a
joke he lived I guess I'm not this is
exactly why Twitter's mad this is
exactly why Twitter's mad look the pig's
F I don't know look I'm not fighting
anybody's battles I I never met the pig
I don't know anything about it so I just
wanted to get food I know nothing about
no pigs so wait if he's mad on a new
Farm he's happy now what's up that pig
is on a new farm and he's happy now
right yeah are you mad I heard that
you're upset no no no I love bacon
what's going on I just heard that you're
upset about what Logan Paul's upset yeah
it's a probably a good thing Mike didn't
come then if Logan's actually angry no
no it's not what a what a
loser what the Mike what a
lame
boy Logan like that idiot can't even see
colors dud what a loser gang for
Life come on
woo it got quiet got it all
right up next guys we
have such an honored guest he is the
winner of the 2023 sound bite Olympics
it's Rich
Lu bring out the
[Applause]
queen
yes
with an
[Applause]
[Music]
Entourage we love you and and
congratulations on winning so nice to
see you you are the queen let me Kiss
the Ring oh thank you finally someone
that respects
me Rich really knows how to make it look
at those shoes man
rich is really he's out here just
he the stage is yours my friend I love
those
[Applause]
shoes so rich is going to be presenting
biggest influencer
[Music]
catastrophe rich is the
queen rich is the queen
Rich can do no
wrong rich is the
queen go ahead
please hello
peasants
welcome thank you Ethan for putting on
this show for me of course man we're
here for you I can't stand
Dan he better not be
here okay
let me see let me see best YouTuber Rich
Lu okay so we got to roll the video best
Tik tocker Rich Lu okay ah here we go
this better be a
check biggest influencer catastrophe
rolling biggest influence a
catastrophe Burning Man leaves a 10 days
stranded a rainstorm decided to crash
the party with a dumping 2 months worth
of rain in just 24 hours and it turned
the desert sand into a sloppy slippery
mud and so as a result you had the
authorities prohibiting all entry and
exit to the festival ground event
organizers telling attendees to just
shelter in place cons serve food and
water got 3/4 of a Terrain travel is
impossible and there's about 70,000
people stranded on a Barron Lake bed we
all slept all night with no house music
bumping everything stopped because of
that horrible the downfall of Beast
Burger YouTube personality Mr Beast is
taking his show to the courtroom as he
sues the company that provides food for
the restaurants that bear his name Mr
Beast lawyers cite a bunch of reviews
that claimed the burgers were disgusting
revolting inedible people questioning
why would Mr bees put his name on such a
horrible product saying that it was the
worst Burger they had ever had this is
what the impossible be style burger is
supposed to look like and this looks
like if somebody drew a burger for me
this is supposed to be a Smash Burger
what the hell is this board ape
convention blinds people turns out most
of the ape Fest venue like pretty much
all of it for the party was decked out
with fluorescent lights somehow some way
at least some of these tubes were very
likely mixed up between party lights and
germicidal sterilization UV radiation
lighting which basically sunburned and
nearly blinded a bunch of their
attendees anyone else's eyes burning
from last night woke up at 3:00 a.m.
with extreme pain and ended up in the
emergency room 30 hours since woke up
with severe eye bur I've visited
emergency hospital and eye clinic and
spent there a total of 6 hours woke up
at 4:00 a.m. and couldn't see anymore
had so much pain in my whole skin is
burned had to go to the hospital Ka at
met breaks havoc in New York City it's a
lot of Y out there right now everybody
who's out there make y safe bro we not
going to do nothing until it's
[Applause]
safe the park has been swarmed and
basically overrun kaat was going to do a
giveaway he announced it on his
Instagram GM feed um and look at this
that's it that's the vehicle right there
that they believe kais sonot is in right
now Kai himself got charged with
first-degree rioting inciting a ride and
unlawful assembly that in addition to
the NYPD saying that 65 people were
arrested 30 of which were
juvenile inside and a riot huh I have
the
receipts biggest influencer catastrophe
is Kai
sonat is Kai here is he you know what
all this is wrong it should have been
Dan ruining my Disney
trip you know it you know what Rich you
know it with all the with all the
Rivalry between you and
Dan you're the queen he's the queen we
need to figure out who is really the
Queen and so so we've just we've let let
us decide we've put together a way to
finally put this to rest we are going to
be
having a drama on Dan's the queen Dan's
the queen and I think you all be
surprised Dan acts like he doesn't care
about this Stu but I know he know Dan
Dan Dan bring them out come out here Dan
Dan Dan Dan Dan bring
[Music]
[Applause]
out
Dan the queen vers Rich the queen who's
the queen all right guys here's how it's
going to
work now these are questions that are
podcast drama related so Dan has a
really good shot but Rich lives and
breathes this stuff so I think the game
is yours to lose rich or to
yeah all right guys so we have 10
questions here's what we're going to do
we're going to alternate between each
one of you guys and and Rich you are
working the crowd boy you you're a
natural you really are want this one
um we're going to alternate and then if
someone gets it wrong the other player
has a opportunity to steal so let's get
right into it okay number one who wants
to go
first the guests uh please Queen the
guest all right Rich question number one
what is the name of Colleen Ballinger's
freak best
friend oh my God
ah don't give it away audience Colleen
Ballinger's best friend freak best
friend he lives with her oh my God James
Charles you already know and a come on
it's rig good guess good guess Dan are
you take the opportunity to steal it
where's Olivia uh that'd be cheating
that'd be cheating uh Colleen's best
friend um
Troy Troy you know what this is one of
the hard ones the answer is Cory
doodo the is that who's that Cory
doodo he's the weirdo friend
that sleep that lives with her okay all
right you weren't paying attention dude
everyone know all right up next so up
next is you Dan uh what was the name of
the YouTuber that Logan Paul posted an
apology to two days after he accused him
of being a
criminal oh coffee's there it is he's on
the
board let's go nice let's go he's on the
board let's go all right
Rich how did Colleen Ballinger meet her
new
husband that was
mancal you love that t ladies and
gentlemen and distinguished Panet panel
of
Judges as Miss gay
America can you repeat the
question
how did Colleen Ballinger meet her new
husband on grinder oh my God Rich can I
get
it
rich Dan how did Colleen Ballinger meet
her new
husband so she was like cheating on the
husb the original dude with the new dude
and uh the room smelled of smoke I
remember where did they meet where did
they meet where did they meet in
Hawaii and he was uh they were in Hawaii
when she cheated on him or uh all right
all right I I don't know they met on
this show of haters back off
oh
right right yeah I'm really pathetic
because like I know all this yeah
you do I live for this okay so it's
one zeros right is that the score
currently okay all right Rich you're
coming up all right what item in Shakur
Shakira's fridge was eaten out of that
was eaten out of that tipped her off
about her husband cheating on
her can I take a
collar all right go ahead take a caller
okay here we go let me see who might
know let me see here
okay what are you doing
here it was jelly perhaps do we Jud do
we accept that jelly or Jam we accept
that must be jelly cuz Jam don't shake
all right how'd you know strawberry jam
there you go actually that was one I
didn't know that one's very
difficult all right we're tied
up Dan here we go what musical movie was
Arana a grande filming when she met her
new boyfriend who had a wife and
child it
is
Wicked oh my God yeah you really
know your bro
yeah well I love that the SpongeBob I
thought it was drama was Next Level
let's let's be real that one even got me
she's not in SpongeBob I thought they
met in SpongeBob no he was SpongeBob in
a musicbob she wasn't Patty s you pay
attention to the power points what the
you talking about I know man I
takeing the L on that one Jes all right
Wicked well done
Dan all right Rich you ready I'm
believe
so what are two things that boogie 2988
29888 listed as reasons he cannot get a
normal job two reasons Boogie cannot I
know this one so he can't get a job
because he said that he was a pord and
he was lazy and had all these medic you
know medical problems and drama and he
was on Social Security you don't want to
get out of bed and work he so damn lazy
get out the house something like that we
would accept yeah most of those yeah
yeah well done well done uh we would
have accepted um felon beats's
ex-wife all right uh has no work
experience last job was at GameStop 20
years ago oh just a moment I have can I
have my assistants come out here I think
it's Eva and Emma can I have my
assistants come please to the front what
is this oh thank you my dear thank you
oh give it up for the assistance we love
her what is
that so Ethan would you sign my book for
me please yeah what book is it okay let
me get it ready I'll you want everything
let me see here I I do not know what's
happen bro you did
not rich I thought we were cool man you
know I'll sign it for you thank you give
it up for
Ethan
you believe this guy bringing this
to me I'm just I can't stop staring at
the cover I'm going to how am I going to
do the show God he's
handsome wow you I love my J shitty
book J have you read J shitty book is
the best book I've ever read you
Jay let me show you the receipts folks
the receipts he signed it
nice all right well done Rich up next
Dan a member of what famous internet
group got into a tiff earlier this year
with a stranger things cast member and
was accused of
misogyny a member of what famous
internet
group with a member of stranger things
cast stranger things cast member he got
into a alter he got into a a beef was
this a PowerPoint when Del I think so
you did he's a member he he's a member
of what inter
group you know it bro search your soul
give him a clue you know this
dig
deep I got nothing all right all right I
got nothing all right you're going to
you're going to kick yourself I know
Richie do you have the answer FaZe Clan
FaZe Clan damn that's your people it's
your favorite the up FaZe is your
people that is my people what's FaZe
Banks going to think about this dude
that's so embarrassing but that D hey
button that in the back you don't even
know the te and you're on the show all
right Rich you're next okay which
celebrity couple who had previously
admitted to not bathing their children
regularly posted a pathetic apology this
year after writing a letter in defense
of their famous predatory and currently
jailed
co-star Jeffree
Star oh my God okay right it's not it's
not correct but I could see where your
head was
at Dan
that's uh that's our peeps Ashton and
munes right damn got it there It Is Well
Done mhm all right this one is going to
you Dan who docks Jack's
films oh come on that's a sniper W right
let's
go that's a layup that was a layup yeah
yeah Rich here we go Which Giant
YouTuber was put under Fire by Rosanna
Pansino a few months
ago come on Rich where you come
on Mr
Beast there Jimmy Beast well done oo
you're going down so what's the current
score it's four to four okay we have a
we have a
tiebreaker so here's what we're going to
do this one's kind of tough whoever
answers first correctly wins okay so
here's the question for both of you what
is the name of coling Ballinger's
[Music]
ex-husband the guy with I'll guy with
the long hair I know it say
it you know it rich oh I know there's no
way he toying with I like you know I
like seeing you burn oh you're sweating
all right let's hear it I watch it there
was a 4our swoop document I know swoop
swoop swoop
swoo people all right RI say it if you
know it you got it just you you know
what folks we've had a lot of drama me
and Dan over the
years he doesn't know the answer as you
no no I know it Ethan I know it don't
start with me today are you just waiting
to hear someone
Whispering with this prayers I just want
to say you know I'm getting older and as
drama King there needs to be a new
supreme
and I want to hand you the next
Crown can we do that you just want to
you want to you caned I can see that but
can I ask you a question do you know the
answer kind
of you know what it's a tie so here's
what I think we need to do Dan you've
proven that you can go toeo Toe with the
very best in drama and I think that
means you're both Queens well we have to
we have to crown him like a listen hold
on I'm from Texas and we do a lot of
pageants so when we Crown the winner you
have to kind of bend down like a little
bit and then you there you go take
photos photo photo yes the new drama
King
Dan looking good bro take your rain
looks nice on you man you have to do the
walk you have to do the walk Take a Bow
take a bow do the
walk I can't stand Dan so honor Dan the
queen
oh I'll take that it's trash I want read
that well actually who m is this
somebody yeah my I have two who's seven
I have seven Mike
seven oh thank you very much folks I
love you all thank you
rich thank you
Rich we love you we really
do thank you for coming great to see
you
he knows that'll work a
crowd yes girl see you
girl all right the next one is a passion
project of mine uh this is going to be
presented by me it's the category of
biggest go ahead and roll
it biggest
award J Shetty kindness to me is any
thought action or word that you can do
or take to make someone's day people
will probably forget what you said
possibly forget what you did but they'll
never forget how you made them feel
imagine if everyone in the world was 5%
Kinder my suggestion is that you go
around and give encouragement on a daily
basis it's a great Habit to get into
kindness spreads faster and kindness is
easy to experience and it
actually one of the things seen is
beautiful that when people are sharing
videos Facebook it's like they feel that
they're getting to spread kindness we
forget and we underestimate how much
just a smile a kind word uh a kind
message or thinking of someone can just
change someone's day and I love those
simple things because I think that those
are things anyone can do and those are
things everyone can appreciate people
are so used to being surrounded by
negativity and criticism and being told
what they can't do how about we went out
and show them what they can do kindness
doesn't have any languages it doesn't
have any barriers like it's beyond all
of that kindness is a language we can
all speak a quote from Nelson Mandela
where he said no one is born hating
another
person uh and if they can learn to hate
they can be taught to love what a
phony what an what an
you seem really nice okay so first of
all can't how did you guys even
get through that video I can't
stand that dude man who does he do he's
such a phony
baloney yeah we trying to have him on
the canel podcast you trying to get J he
left me on
breed funny there's nobody else in that
category that's your passor well let's
see who won okay still a
m somehow winning with only 84% I didn't
give you a
choice I'll take the other
20% well there's interesting writing but
Jay shett you are the biggest
you man I see you I know what
you're doing I'm on to you and the world
will understand that you are not the
good guy you yeah thank yeah J
sh you suck you bro if he
didn't have beautiful eyes he'd be
nothing do you understand so beautiful
eyes to R oh what he what oh he B
he did barbecue with Oprah Winfrey give
him a break dude that guy who cares
dick actually a r in thank you to our
wonderful fans this is Ethan
2.8% actually in a close third Jimmy Lee
2.6% I guess he did end up being part of
the show
we love you Jimmy at least I
do you all right up next we have a very
special performance you know her you
love her it's Sam with Grimace shake and
fortnite get it
[Applause]
Sam
please sing along you know this
[Music]
song
the
[Music]
for
Shing
for sh
[Music]
for
[Applause]
[Music]
that boy can hit the
greedy
[Applause]
[Music]
wow Standing Ovation I mean really wow
get her
out absolutely gorgeous all right so up
next we've got
um e how are
you hello
hello Martin what are you doing
here hello
everybody you're smart in your personal
water
some
why are you I it's just so you know you
are not part of the show come on I need
to be part of the show because water is
the most important beverage in our lives
Ethan without that we wouldn't be here
mean okay but you didn't invent water I
mean I am drinking water yeah come on no
but actually it's okay that water what
you're drinking this time last time I
had a little question about that that's
the Reas Arad you like the
geyser yeah Crystal Geyser a great
Spring Water what do you want by the way
we need to talk a little bit about the
last episode where you said like water
has no impact on New York's Pizza it has
Bagels I stand by that Martin they can
it's the Bagels too much
going on in there man it's actually a
fact because the lack of calcium and
magnesium in that
water you you are you here for a point
better cut to the chase water boy I
think we in the Derby theater
and in a regular base the Oscars are
here and I'm the Golden Boy here
obviously today so I thought we need to
do uh the best water contest as well
well there's there is no water category
absolutely there's a water
category okay well there's not so I
don't know what you expect no no no no
no we have to oh what the
best water come on Ocean it works
best water stupid
river River
[Music]
Lake
P mountain
[Applause]
spring all right I don't know what you
think you're doing I don't know who you
coordinated but security is time to get
rid of the water gu what security
there's no this isn't a real category
bro come on guys water is not just water
huh mountain spring water that is the
water you're going to drink e huh that's
the water you're going to drink thank
you nice to see you I'm getting it I'm
getting it guys always crash in our live
shows okay okay
okay category
water of course it was going to be
mountain
spring all right well that was Mar thank
you thank you so
much so are we are we skipping what I
just saw are we skipping
something okay worst award show
presented by me
we got to slam through this you know
what who it is go ahead and roll
it SC worst award
[Music]
show the
streames you love your cars you love
your cars and I love my gaming here are
um Ella stop laughing guys come on man
yes yes yes ice cream so good gang
gang J Shetty I'm here tonight to
present the Elevate prize get loud award
for social good creator of the year is I
felt gay Mr
Beast you know if you're going to keep
giving him Awards he really needs to
show up check out more winners from this
year's streamy Awards podcast on purpose
with Jay Shetty I don't think we Cate
the transitions enough in
life yeah embarrassing to win an award
there embarrassing to go up on
stage in front of them you won one
though right no hey did you were creator
of the here yes I should have planted
trees that's a that's a big honor I won
one for getting hit by a crane what did
you win I won a stream me for getting
hit by a crane best hit by a crane yeah
uh 20 you're in a league of your own
brother
2021 greatest mortal injury near and
dear to heart dobert is down the street
did we mention I don't know what you're
talking about all right I also have a
steamy
Cody doic is down the street all right
with 97.3% streaming I hope you're
watching you are the worst award show
you guys
suck
[Music]
cringe I mean J shett best podcast like
move
on does anyone actually watch J shett by
show a
hands be serious like I'm not going to
judge you I see one guy I I'm genuinely
one a pull of people that actually know
and care about this
loser there's literally like two hands
in the air I mean this this is but it's
the same this man loves J sh he Lo
J yeah I see you
bro I see you I got you in facial
recognition I'm going to find out who
you
are you're in the database buddy this
guy's a j shete fan he's all up he's all
up in that what do you like about
him his motivational he tells
you does a cold plunge every day who
gives a
I didn't I didn't mean to make I
didn't mean to make regret Hest water
why do you like J
shett his eyes eyes really sensitive
topic for you bro that's fair to be
honest I can't even hate on him for the
eyes all right thank you uh
appreciate you thank you all right up
next we have a
special this is a big moment guys
uh toxic gossip train performed by Zach
and
[Applause]
[Music]
Olivia
[Applause]
Zach said he wasn't ready yo what
happened
whoa did the train
stop all
[Applause]
[Music]
aboard
he how is
everybody oh my God you guys look Beauty
to yeah all right hit it
[Music]
cam you know
it
[Music]
as
entering Ching out the track of this
information
[Music]
got I've been sh my life all
night
over
years my
heart because of that I feel Chang my
behavior I couldn't
tell but that's not very
interesting is it
okay
God the track
[Music]
Miss
down
track you me to
[Music]
CL
down the
[Music]
track
you got
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
the
thank I got a ton of shirts I'm going to
give you
that
here anyone else I want to hook
[Applause]
[Music]
you all right um up next uh is
the all right then then you can afford
your
own I got it it's on
me say
what you want a shirt where are you all
right let me
try
[Applause]
all right all right we'll do some more
later uh I I have like five left but
we'll we'll get them all
up we love you
Trisha
you're out there you're the
best okay we've heard all the songs and
now we have Zach the
artiste to present best influencer
song Hello
everybody go ahead and roll
it um first and foremost before I get to
the award um it's a true honor to be
here and perform for you
guys
um it's surreal because I sat there for
Neil Young I sat there for Bob Dylan and
now it's us and I get to play For You
Beautiful People so thank you very much
you are Bob Dylan do Dylan you're Bob
Bernstein you shredded bro yeah thank
you thank you all very much so I'm here
to present best influencer
song roll it best influencer song I
would hate me too I
tx2 spiciest
[Music]
drama I am rectangular by Sha
Stevens I traveled a th km to New York
City to do
this I am
rectangular I Feel It In My Bones I am
rectangular
chestnuts
[Applause]
[Music]
I hi
by Colleen
Ballinger hey it's been a while since
you saw my face I haven't been doing so
great so I took a little break toxic
gossip
train of with painful
accusations toxic gossip
train steam all over someone's
reputation nightmare by
sleep when you're not
hey that's my
[Music]
[Applause]
song Grim Shake in
forler upy
GR
was
eveny a sh
for
awesome and the winner
is grimy shaking
for come accept come accept your award W
this is
amazing speech
speech wow my very first
steamy thank you guys for voting for me
that is incredibly skibbidy Ohio 10 RIS
of all of you thank
you Mayo for
Sam Mayo for
[Applause]
Sam love you thank you well done Sam
that song really who is who that really
was such a uh phenomenal song
man yeah all right so we're moving on
where this is our ultimate category this
is the big one this is a huge one this
is most dramatic Creator I mean this is
basically the best actor this is the
best film this is the big one this is
the la la land La La Land yeah oh yeah
so without further Ado most dramatic
Creator hello
everyone I'm so excited to be presenting
most most dramatic Creator let's take a
look at the
nominees most tramatic
[Music]
Creator colen
Ballinger
Logan
[Music]
ball
excuse Ethan
[Music]
[Applause]
Klein Steven
Crowder
and the winner is for most dramatic
Creator at the steamies
2023 is Ethan
[Applause]
Klein no
way what is this is this a
flashlight I'm so honored thank you guys
this is really a special this is really
a special moment for me I'm touched I'm
honored I'm beside this is really
special this is a what is this let me
open
it
what it's a steamy
flashlight Malik made this specially for
this award
show so now I can celebrate in
style hell no this this is way too
valuable bro also it's been
used wow this is such an honor I'm
really grateful thank you everybody for
believing in me for voting for me and uh
you know what can I say I'm a I am a
catty little
I am a hater ass
and I thank you all for supporting
me in that and enabling my worst traits
thank
you so up
next we have a special final uh sendoff
video made by our very own Cameron G
grants we do this every year it's a
year-end wrap-up video where we look
back at some of our favorite moments of
the year we've been through a lot so
let's enjoy this together shall
we Olivia are you okay in there always
ow come
on
button is going to save us all you guys
we have sponsors lining up we're never
going to get in trouble
again I made the really unfortunate and
stupid decision to play this uh Stupid
sound bite song of this guy singing
chestnuts over an open fire C minute
here at the
[Music]
podcast
wow that look
so Ethan Ethan you look
[Music]
amazing so I came here because I finally
got the result you never get and guess
what it is I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
pregnant you
[Music]
see don't put your hands up put your
hands up I'm not going to ask you
[Music]
again did you just misspeak or are you
putting paper towels in the toilet that
so yeah know I didn't misspeak it's a
paper towel okay that's why it's getting
CL throwing down
[Music]
[Applause]
toilet show us child
pornography all right so this whole
thing started Mark Elliot emailed me a
few weeks ago have a lot of interest in
Nexium I think Keith reneer is a modern
day genius Mark is an award-winning
speaker who lived with Tourette Syndrome
for 20 years and then beat it completely
mind over body that shocked me Mark is
actually on the phone and thanks man for
being here that's so it's so awesome to
to meet someone like you that's great
thank you uh so much for having me reer
is was convicted for jeez it was like
seven different felonies huh but he he
didn't do any of
it we should probably justune the
extortion the identity theft of forced
labor conspiracy to commit identity
theft exploiting of a child forced
labor cuz like we got to convince
everyone that Keith is like a cool
dude they should take immediate action
and if they can't or they won't United
States Attorney General should point
you see this photo of you guys of The
Three
Amigos you know you don't know how to
turn off Zoom you're trying but you
can't get away you're trying and I hope
reneer dies in prison I really do
Caitlyn Jenner's organization who
famously ran someone over but that's
actually not the most important thing
about Caitlyn
Jenner um yes so B I've got a new book
it's from it's like a h reference you're
really clutching at like this peace I
always have my mouth open you know like
mhm looks really natural when you do it
I don't think people are born gay yeah I
think that they they choose it's a
choice do you choose every day to have
to be attracted to women no I wouldn't
say so right I'm just naturally
attracted to women
right so do I need to connect the dots
or you got it oh I just want to be left
alone I want to pack this with you this
is interesting okay slaves had good
relationships with their owners huh some
slaves had good relationships with their
masters therefore slaver was elled oh
okay sure I mean that's content man it's
it's original content have a good night
have a good night thank
[Music]
you the bottom getting
[Applause]
[Music]
he just just wi them
out we 100% are not getting leftovers
two weeks in a row God damn it I I'll
I'll call Brad real back y we're live
right now Brad the B the legend the
stallion he piss thanks for taking care
of her bro stop stop it's not like
[Music]
that I'll be there every
[Applause]
day
the
[Music]
[Applause]
can someone gra me a drink I need you
know I like to have seven on my desk on
it
oh unwarranted Avatar
hate my beautiful son Bruce is here go
ahead say laa to
everybody thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
good I don't even care about the money
anymore they're not giving it back I
will spend a million dollars to legally
them in the ass this dispute it has
been resolved so thank you
bbtv you've returned the
money you've done the right thing thank
you thank
you
okay why is he wearing a top hat it's
beautiful it's perf it's just what I
wanted I mean it's just that's my
beautiful boy it looks it's that's shred
you
[Music]
know
so you guys headed out now cam uh I hope
[Applause]
so thank you everybody
thank you guys for an amazing year I'm
so grateful for all you guys I mean look
at this this is insane Jesus Christ y
thank you so
[Music]
much really means a lot
so thank you thank you I feel skin you
are looking good bro
um Encore I
think passport oh
we don't have time for that right Dan we
don't have time for
passport well did you want to do EOP
pit do we have time for E pit at least
I'm so sorry but we have to get out of
here maybe next year we'll get to the
eel
pit damn maybe we prepared a whole
segment for
it you told us this was an hour I did
did I yeah I did tell you it was an hour
you got to pull the receipts on that I'm
happy to be here I'm sorry loved it no
thank you so much for having me you're
an inspiration I'm this whole show been
sick I love this family and thank you
for having us love you
guys thank you guys love you I
love you
Logan Ethan it's awesome to be here love
you guys you guys the best audience in
the world we love you foot
soldiers oh yeah you guys are awesome I
love you so much give Tana love I mean
this is
outrageous we love you I love you come
on I love you forever and ever I want to
say my beautiful lovely
wife a third baby on the way and she
looks so
amazing thank you everyone I am honestly
speechless it's amazing to see you all
you're all so beautiful so nice kind
beautiful people
thank you for coming out
tonight
and thank you for everything you do for
us also I want to thank I this is the
best
crew you guys know that's
true there's no show that runs and
they're part of the show they're funny
and entertaining but they actually do a
lot of too you know like they they
work out here at 8:00 a.m. and that's
just the tip of the iceberg but um you
guys are the best
reallying can we end with a chant family
family family family family family
family
stop we're like a weird
cult the friendliest of Cults absolutely
go ahead Logan did you want to say
something the friendliest of Cults oh
and a a reminder from our legal team we
are not going out for pizza after this
right I don't even know what pizza
is yeah and I if you are holding crypto
zo I've been assured that it is going to
it's going to be doing really great we
working on it I don't know what else
around the
clock tell Logan I said hi by the
way he's watching
hi we love
you but um anyway we're about to take a
break for three weeks and uh
although it's sad to see you guys say
goodbye to you guys for that brief time
well we'll be back thank you for another
year of great shows and I thank you guys
so much for all your
support it really is amazing to see I I
don't know I don't know how this
happened this is you know thank you guys
so much I hope you guys had
fun and
uh we had a lot of fun doing it for you
guys you guys want to say anything
go ahead here I love
you and thank you so so much to our
incredible boss Ethan Klein you
made we love you we love you thank you
thank yeah we're sitting like we have
the job ever so thank you so
much genuinely I I can't even say it
like y'all are the best like
Nobody Does it everybody does such an
incredible job and in their own way and
it's just it really is oh Ela throwing
out shirts but thank you yes Ethan thank
you for everything you do we love you
thank you for being so generous so car
than we appreciate you and also I want
to also thank Dan Atlas who makes
everything possible Dan the weight of
the world on his back Dan did you want
to say anything nice about
me yeah of course Ethan's a great boss
he takes wonderful care of us um it is a
genuine honor and privilege to work with
him for these past six years and um as
much as uh we made buttthe heads on air
uh it's all love it is all love
so I didn't force him to say that didn't
put him on the spot Dan is the
queen Dan is the queen thank you guys to
Jeff and tana and the Logan Paul my
goodness thank you guys so much for
being here thank you so much thank you
thank you thank
you all right thank you for joining us
how are we doing on time Dan we got to
go we're like we're like done done done
if we go too long we're like
[Music]
love love you guys
you
bye
guys
you I love that
hoodie hey take that off not in like a
weird way not like a weird hi
[Music]
guys
your U we actually have jade stones we
wanted to shoot out I forgot jade
stones who wants a Jade rock blasted at
them who wants a
Shir come on show your hype come on come
on that this is a rock who is
wow it's off it's a plus
[Music]
you